Aller Zeiten exklusiv von Time Life.
Für dein nächstes Ultraschall-Release kannst du das ja hier mal auf-
Starten Sie Ihre VADER Collection jetzt auf zwei CDs für nur 21,99 Euro. Wenn Sie per Bank Einzug zahlen, erhalten Sie eine weitere Doppel-CD gratis dazu.
Was machst du denn hier?
Aber das ist noch nicht alles. Rufen Sie in den nächsten 10 Minuten an und sparen Sie 5 Euro.
Also rein in den Rechner, raus aus dem Rechner, vom Mischpult zum Rechner und wieder zurück.
Rufen Sie in den nächsten 10 Minuten an und starten Sie Ihre VADER Collection für nur 16,99 Euro. Bezahlen Sie per Bank Einzug und Sie erhalten diese Doppel-CD gratis dazu.
Aber es ist auch, soll ich euch sagen, wer der Nick Satoshi Nakamoto ist? Der Typ heißt Nick Szabo, ist schon eigentlich seit Monaten bekannt, aber irgendwie ist er ziemlich ruhig geblieben. Aber wenn er von euch, also der heißt auch Nick Szabo, also NS, Satoshi Nakamoto. Jedenfalls, der hat auch schon das BitGold, ne wie heißt das? Auch eine Cryptocurrency. Also der ist auch so ein Professor, beschäftigt sich mit Cryptocurrencies und alles was der macht passt genau zu Bitcoin. Und da sind die vor einem Jahr oder einem halben irgendwie schon mal drauf gekommen. Irgendwann, einer meinte, er hätte es gefunden. Und dann haben auch manche Leute so geforscht und gesagt, ja passt ganz gut. Und aber irgendwie wurde nicht nachgehakt. Da ist kein News-Reporter zu dem hingegangen und hat den mal ausgehorcht oder wie auch immer. Aber ich finde auch, ich glaube der Typ müsste das eigentlich sein.
Wie schreibt der sich?
Nick Zabo, S-Z-A-B-O. S-Z-A-B-O. Und vielleicht ist der das auch nicht. Ja, das kann ja alles sein. Und vielleicht ist ja Bitcoin auch gar nicht eine Einzelperson und so. Aber vielleicht ist ja auch nur ein Teil von so einer Gang. Aber der würde auf jeden Fall ziemlich gut da reinpassen. Und da sollte man mal jemanden hinschicken und sollte man mal ein bisschen mehr nachforschen.
Müsste man mal.
Müsste man mal, ja. Ist auf jeden Fall besser, als irgendwelche Typen zu suchen, die auch Satoshi heißen. Aber ja, der Satoshi, der Unechte, der hat ja richtig viel Geld bekommen. Die haben ja irgendwie 20.000 Dollar schon für den zusammen gesammelt.
So viel ist schon zusammen gekommen, also in Bitcoin.
Ja, umge, ich weiß nicht.
Wie für den gesammelt, wieso?
Na ja, die Argumentation war, wir sammeln jetzt für ihn. Wenn das nicht ist, dann ist das einfach die Entschädigung von der Bitcoin-Community dafür, dass er so in die Öffentlichkeit gezogen wurde. Sorry. Also auch wenn es jetzt nicht die Schuld der Szene war, aber irgendwie, sie zeigen sich zumindest erkenntlich. Und wenn das ist, naja, dann werden sie eh auch ausreichend dankbar. Dann wird es schon den richtigen treffen. 20.000 Dollar.
Ich glaube ja, 18.000 habe ich irgendwas gelesen.
Kann man sich schon mal ein Met-Eagle von kaufen.
Ja, wenn er es annimmt. So, Nick Szabo. Aber von Bitcoin steht hier nichts, oder? Doch, doch. Achso, und der hat auch schon mal einen... Tja, nichts Genaues weiß man nicht.
Ja, aber der zumindest ist mal im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen, hat sich profimäßig, also als Professor halt, mit Cryptocurrencies beschäftigt. Und das, also ich denke schon, dass es jemand sein muss, der sich da profimäßig mit beschäftigt hat.
Nick, sag uns, wer du bist.
Der kleine Nick.
Da könnte die Bild-Zeitung ja mal jemanden hinschicken.
Das Münchner Abendblatt.
Genau, in Smallland.
Verstehe. Na gut, dann wurde es ja auch wieder ganz wild, dann gab es irgendwie auch noch jemanden, der gepostet hat, hier Dorian Nakamoto hat den PGP-Key von dem Original Satoshi und so weiter gesigned, aber das war alles nur ein totaler Hoax. Und hast du hier mitbekommen, was es hier mit diesen 180.000 Bitcoin-Transfer auf sich hatte?
Das ist alles ein bisschen unklar. Die hacken ja da Mt. Gox und den Blog, den Zugang von dem, wer ist der? Karpelis? Mark Karpelis oder so. Und ich blicke da nicht mehr durch, wer da was hackt. Und dann weiß man ja auch immer nicht, ob alles echt ist und so weiter. Deswegen lasse ich sowas immer ein paar Tage sacken, aber ja, keine Ahnung.
180.000 Bitcoin hat einer rumgeschoben, ja? Für 0 Bitcoin-Fee.
Was sind denn Coin Days Destroyed?
Kannst du das gut erklären?
Ich klick noch das Fragezeichen, ich wusste es mal, aber keine Ahnung.
Also ich kann es ja mal kurz versuchen. Also man versucht ja immer so die Aktivität, sozusagen das Transaktionsvolumen des gesamten Netzwerks in irgendeiner Form in eine Größe zu packen. Mit wie viel Geld wird gehandelt? Beim normalen Markt ist das irgendwie relativ klar, weil dann hast du immer so Transaktionen, die von Person zu Person gehen. Hier ist aber nur Transaktion, die so von Wallet zu Wallet gehen und du weißt halt nicht, ob es sich dabei um dieselbe Person handelt, die quasi nur linke Tasche, rechte Tasche was macht. Und dieses Coin, der ist destroyed, ist quasi der Versuch, eine Unit dafür zu bekommen, wie das Transaktionsvolumen ist. Und die berücksichtigt eben, wie lange eine Coin, die da transferiert wird, vorher nicht mehr angefasst wurde. Sprich, umso länger eine Coin nicht bewegt wurde und umso höher der Wert davon ist, also umso mehr Coins, umso älter die sind, umso größer wird dieser Wert.
Das heißt, wenn ich einen Bitcoin schiebe, der ist genau 24 Stunden alt, dann habe ich einen Coin, der ist zerstört?
Ja.
Und wenn ich einen Bitcoin schiebe, der eine Woche alt ist, dann sind es sieben Bitcoins, die ich zerstöre. Okay, das heißt, man muss jetzt die Zahl, die da steht, was ist das?
143 Millionen.
Durch 180.000 teilen, und dann weiß man, wann die zum letzten Mal waren.
Genau, das waren wir drei Jahre.
Das sind relativ viele Alte dabei, oder?
Ja, dann können die ja schon mal nicht von Wandgog sein, wenn die so alt sind. Außerdem kann man doch gucken in der Transaction History, von wann der Blobbel da ist.
Darf ich mal kurz anmerken, dass zum Beispiel Dennis gerade für mich so soundtechnisch zum Beispiel nicht so doll klingt.
Das ist immer so bei Dennis, ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Der Dars hat halt nicht so eine coole Stimme.
Du hast einfach eine leise Stimme. Ich?
Ja.
Meine Mama hat immer gesagt, ich soll nicht so schreien.
Irgendwie, irgendwas wird mit seiner Stimme da rumgemodelt.
Ist das denn hier das richtige Mikro und so?
Das ist immer so bei Dennis. Dennis ist immer leise.
Weil der Timmer mich immer schon so runterregelt.
Erstens tue ich das nicht. Ich kann dich auch hier noch mal hoch regeln, wenn du möchtest. Das war der falsche, Entschuldigung.
Deswegen, siehste. So, und jetzt bist besser. Ich versuche mein Mikro immer nicht so ganz an meine Grasmaske zu machen.
Ja, dann wedert er halt immer so rum.
Was ist jetzt rot da hinten bei dem Pegel da?
Du bist durch die Decke geschossen.
Das war jetzt ein bisschen zu viel. War nicht so schlimm.
Aber geht gleich wieder weg, oder wie?
Können wir mal einen Test machen? Mit dem Fahrrad nicht in den ersten Wagen!
Da ist aber rot geworden.
Naja, ich habe da noch einen Kompressor drauf, für solche Fälle. Deswegen wird ja hier komprimiert, nicht?
Das war übrigens eine Ansage aus der U-Bahn.
Clemens hat auf jeden Fall den Berlin-Test schon mal bestanden.
Schöne Stelle.
Zurückbleiben!
Nee, nee, nee, das ist viel zu höflich. Ich hab zurückbleiben, ich sag's!
Zum Gott, jetzt fallen alle von den Geräten.
Außerdem hat ihr ja Holgi zu sitzen, das geht noch viel schlimmer.
Ja, das ist Holgi-Proof.
Das ist Holgi-Proof, genau.
Ach, du hast den Holgi-Kompressor drauf.
So, was gab's noch bei Bitcoin?
Naja, dann ging's ja irgendwie mit Mount Gox furchtbar weiter irgendwie. Hast du diese... Ach, wo hab ich denn jetzt diesen Link mit dieser These? Verdammt, ich dachte, den hätt ich hier drin. Manno, meine Vorbereitung.
Dieter von, oder was meinst du?
Naja, es gab doch eine schöne Theorie, wie das jetzt alles gelaufen sein soll. Hast du das gesehen?
Mit dem Bot, den er da angeblich programmiert hat, der irgendwie massiv in den Handel eingegriffen hat.
Ja, genau.
Und der Source-Grund ist raus von seiner Plattform, der PHP.
Die Dönster Datenbank haben sie irgendwie gelegt und haben dann irgendwie alles mal zusammengerechnet und sind irgendwie auf 950.000 Bitcoins, die da eigentlich fehlen, gekommen und nicht 750.000. Also nichts Genaues weiß man nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall mittlerweile klar, Mount Gox scheint schon seit Jahren oder mehr oder weniger von Anfang an auf extrem dünnen Eis gesegelt zu sein. Und da war nie alles in Ordnung. Und die waren wahrscheinlich potenziell schon seit längerem im Wesentlichen im Konkurs und haben irgendwie durch zahlreiche Fehler schon immer viel zu wenig Geld gehalten, etc. und deswegen wahrscheinlich auch diese merkwürdigen Spiele mit irgendwie langsamer Auszahlung und nicht so viel auf einmal und so weiter, um das irgendwie alles noch in den Griff zu kriegen. Da hätte man wahrscheinlich auch schon ein bisschen früher...
Ich hab den Mount Gox noch nie vertraut.
Ja, zu Recht wahrscheinlich. Ich meine, vertrauen tue ich diesen ganzen System nicht.
Den Bitcoin-System.
Ja.
Aber irgendwie war Mount Gox mir schon immer irgendwie besonders shady.
Ich dachte eigentlich genau anders. Ich dachte, das sind die einzigen, denen man irgendwie vertrauen kann, weil alle anderen, ich meine, Mount Gox sind jetzt nicht die ersten, wo es schief gegangen ist. Sondern es gab es ja vorher schon lauter Börsen. Auch hier in Deutschland gab es ja auch schon so Typen, der dann irgendwie, okay, dem haben sie es verboten, glaube ich. Der war dann doch nicht weg, aber er durfte nicht mehr und all sowas. Aber es gab es auch schon lauter Leute, die halt einen Exchange gemacht haben. Und so nach so ein paar Monaten, wenn die Tasche voll war, schwupp weg waren sie. Also das gab es vorher reichlich. Und Mount Gox waren für mich eigentlich die, die von Anfang an irgendwie dabei waren und die halt am größten und am stabilsten waren, bis halt das Peng gemacht hat. Also kann man bei Bitcoin auch sagen wie im echten Leben, man soll sein scheiß Geld nicht auf der Bank liegen lassen, ist immer blöd. Dann kommen die irgendwann und ziehen das ein, irgendeine Krise kommt und das ist weg.
Ein Freund von mir, der hat mal im Call Center von der Bank gearbeitet und der meinte nur, steck dein Geld ins Kopf, Kissen.
Ja gut, aber du kannst ja bei deiner Wallet auch nicht so sicher sein.
Ja, aber sicherer als irgendwie, wenn es woanders liegt.
Na, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Also kannst du zumindest mehr für deine eigene Sicherheit tun.
Mach dir eine Paper-Wolle, druck die mehrmals aus, platzier die an verschiedenen Orten und dann ist gut. Aber bei Mt. Gox oder bei irgendeinem Exchange, deine Bitcoins liegen zu lassen, da macht's einfach, die sind einfach weg, wenn die wollen schon, sind die weg. Was ich letztens gemacht hab, ist, weil ich halt keinen Bock mehr hab auf irgendwelche komischen Aktionen und ich renne auch nicht mit meinem Laptop rum und dann irgendwie eine dicke Wallet aufzumachen. Ich hab jetzt hier so ein Blockchain-Info-Wallet, hab da irgendwie 0,1 Bitcoin hingeschoben, bin in Room 77 gegangen, hab gleich auch die kompletten 0,1 Bitcoin da ausgegeben, gleich meine Kumpels eingeladen.
Ich war nicht dabei.
Sag ich Bescheid nächstes Mal. Jedenfalls kannst du dann direkt über deine Webseite bezahlen oder du kannst dir, wenn du einen Developer-Account hast, die Blockchain-Info-Wallet-App direkt für dein iPhone bauen und darauf packen, die funktioniert. Und das tut ganz gut. Und da packe ich nur so viel drauf, wie ich brauche, so geldkartenmäßig, also nichts, da die ganzen Bitcoins draufschieben, sondern echt immer nur so 0, irgendwas Bitcoins und dann muss das reichen. Und wenn jetzt alle fragen, was hier der nächste Exchange ist, den man benutzen kann, um seine Bitcoins zu tauschen, ich habe keine Ahnung. Vielleicht macht der Hoeneß ja eine Bank auf.
Also, Bitstamp funktioniert nach wie vor gut. Allerdings ist dieser Verifikationsprozess ein bisschen nervig. Also bis sie da dann einmal dich zum Trading freigegeben haben.
Das war bei Mt. Gox aber auch so am Ende.
Ja, aber das benutzen, glaube ich, die Jungs, die ich jetzt hier noch so...
Sind die eigentlich Deutsche oder sind die...
Nee, die sind, glaube ich, aus Slowenien.
Ah, dann sind es die Typen dieser Slush, der auch diesen einen der ersten Pools hatte. Slushpool, der auch dieses Strattenprotokoll gemacht hat, oder? Nehme ich mal an.
Weiß ich nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall ist die Seite eigentlich, also vom User Interface, ganz schnuffig und die haben bisher, glaube ich, noch keinen großen Fnord geleistet.
Ja, dann gibt es ja dieses Coinbase oder so in den USA.
So und bitcoin.de ist, glaube ich, auch relativ smooth gesale.
bitcoin.de ist gerade das, was der hier anzeigt.
Na ja. Aber bei bitcoin.de hat man auch so ein bisschen Sparkassen-Feeling, finde ich. Wieso?
Was ist denn daran Sparkassen-Feeling?
Ach, die sind irgendwie so, die sind halt so ungeil. Also es ist alles so, du weißt schon, du gehst halt, das fühlt sich halt so an wie in eine Sparkasse reinlaufen bei bitcoin.de.
Haben die alles in Kobol programmiert oder was?
Ja, du weißt schon, was ich meine, es riecht da komisch. Also in der Sparkasse riecht es halt auch so, speziell Sparkasse. Die Leute gucken wie Sparkasse und bitcoin.de von der Bedienung her und so, das hat so Sparkassen-Geruch für mich. Ja, das kann jeder aber natürlich ganz anders sehen.
Ja, ich hab den Link hier mal gepostet, Peter R.'s Theorie on the Collapse of Mt. Gox. Ich krieg's jetzt gerade nicht so gut zusammengefasst, weil das eine längere Kette ist, aber er belegt, also er unterstellt vor allem diesem Kapelle ein gewisses Handeln und belegt das eben mit den tatsächlich beobachteten Aktivitäten in der Mt. Gox-Börse und wie die Preise hoch und runter gegangen sind und was seiner Meinung nach auch erklärt, warum dann der Mt. Gox-Preis immer höher lag als den, also wenn das stimmt, dann war einfach dieser Beschiss so dermaßen umfassend, dass, ja, ist einfach, also dieser Marktkapelle ist, ich weiß nicht, ob der nochmal irgendwie auf den grünen Zweig kommt.
Ich hoffe nicht. Wir sollen in der Hölle schmoren.
Ja, aber vielleicht sitzt er dann irgendwann in einem Haus neben Kimbe irgendwie in Neuseeland.
Kim Schmitz, der sollte Bitcoin-Exchange aufmachen.
Mega-Bitcoin!
Mega-Coin!
Der macht seine eigene Währung auf.
Wenn da 744.000 oder wie viele auch immer über 500.000 Bitcoins verschwunden sind, ist ja echt eine Menge Geld von vielen, vielen Leuten. Das heißt, da sind viele, viele Leute nicht happy. Und diese vielen, vielen Leute, da denke ich mal, da gibt es einige, die nur so einen Teil davon bei Mt. Gox liegen hatten und den anderen Teil hatten den nicht liegen und die sind sozusagen immer noch scheißerreich. Und ich hoffe, dass die sauer genug sind, dass dieser Markt-Typ da in seinem Leben nicht mehr happy wird.
Das könnte durchaus passieren.
Ja, ich glaube, der hat jetzt schon Schwierigkeiten mit dem Happy-Werden. Aber wie siehst du denn das mit diesen, ich meine, diese ganzen Bitcoins, die sind ja jetzt nicht, die diffundieren ja nicht. Die gehören jetzt irgendeiner Wallet. Man weiß ja auch welcher.
Alle auf einer?
Ja, ich meine, man kann ja im Prinzip jegliches Geld theoretisch nachvollziehen bei Bitcoin.
Wenn du noch durchblickst, wenn jetzt die Daten ankommen, schon ja.
So, was heißt diese Coins, wenn sie dann irgendwann mal wieder ausgegeben werden?
Ja, aber da gibt es ja, das ist schon richtig, aber...
Ich meine, das ist doch alles sozusagen, das sind doch Scheine, das ist doch alles nummerierte Scheine.
Ja, aber klein, kleine nummerierte Scheine. Und zweitens, die werden halt gewaschen. Fertig. Da gibt es ja hier Cleaning Services, ich weiß nicht, wie die genau heißen, aber so Geldwäsche, Bitcoin Geldwäsche gibt es ja. Da gehen die rein, werden so lange aufgesplittet, bis du einfach nicht mehr durchblickst. Du könntest sagen, in der Theorie kommt es jetzt zwar und da, aber die Personen haben halt nichts mehr miteinander zu tun. Das wird da reingepumpt und kommt am Ende gespreadet wieder raus und dann hast du da keinen Überblick mehr. Also...
Nicht so einfach. Hab ich schon, hab ich schon, hab ich schon. Alles vergessen.
Musst du wie bei Office Space etwa auch Money Laundry im Dictionary nachgucken.
Ich bin ein ganz unbeschriebenes Blatt. Naja, andere Exchanges hatten auch so ihre Probleme, hier irgendwie FlexCoin, ich weiß nicht, habt ihr die vorher schon mal gecheckt? Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab neute Storys gelesen.
Die haben sich irgendwie alles klauen lassen und dieses Polonix irgendwie auch und die hatten also so dermaßen erbärmliche Fehler in ihrer Transaktionssoftware, also einfach ihre ganzen Checks und Balances.
Alles nicht verstanden.
Hat einfach vorne und hinten nicht funktioniert. Das ist also wirklich, ja, zum Heulen. So, Dennis, du hast ja auch noch was mit Bitcoin.
Na, das, was sozusagen das ganze Drama ausgelöst hat, diese Bitcoin-Mollability, die ist ja kein Blockchain-Problem. Das heißt, die Blockchain ist ja, wie sie sagen, die konsistent und hat keine Macke. Das heißt, keine Bitcoins waren je gefährdet.
Also, dass die...
Oh, Bitcoins, wir haben's.
Genau. Aber optisch halt und so war das halt schon ein Problem. Und das fixen die gerade alles in der Bitcoin, im GitHub, kann man dazugucken. Und die neueste Version, die... Also wurde ich schon ewig dran bauen, weil wir haben ja die 08 schon ewig und 085 und 086 und so weiter. Und die 09 ist halt wirklich ein riesengroßer Sprung. Das sieht man auch an der Changelist, die ist echt zierisch lang. Und da gab's jetzt, Ende letzten Jahres, glaube ich schon ein Release-Candidate. Und jetzt gab's vor irgendwie, ja, einer Woche circa, gab's den zweiten, den wollte ich gleich ausprobieren. Und der ist mir natürlich gleich sofort um die Ohren geflogen. Da bin ich gleich in irgendeinem Channel da, Bitcoin Dev. Hab gesagt, Jungs, hier läuft nicht. Und so meinten sie, ja, wussten sie. Das ist halt so, dass irgendwie das Quotet, was die da nutzen, läuft unter Mavericks, nicht? Da gibt's irgendein Font-Rendering-Problem. Aber unter 10.8 und 10.7 und so läuft. Also wer irgendwie Probleme mit seiner Wallet hat, oder wie auch immer, also Vollbackups machen immer Jungs, da wisst ihr ja. Aber der könnte halt die 09.0 Release-Candidate 2 ausbilden. Nur wenn er Mavericks hat, dann könnt ihr euch das gleich sparen und könnt weiter warten. Weil ich hab schon mal nachgeguckt worden, es gibt immer noch keine neue Version.
Die sollen einfach dieses Kuté wegspringen.
Ja, dieses Kuté, das hat doch keine Zukunft.
Ja, die sollen aber eine ordentliche Lippe machen, bin auch der Meinung.
Haben die so viel Geld, sind die nicht in der Lage, sich mal eine ordentliche GUI-Programmieren zu lassen?
Vielleicht haben sie die 180.000 Bitcoins da geschoben, damit sie mal an die Developer bezahlen können. Aber sie droppen Support für OS X 10.5, das fliegt raus. Ab dann ist halt auch 64 Bit auf allen Plattformen möglich. Oder sie machen, glaube ich, 64 Bit own, ich weiß gar nicht so genau.
Ja, 32 Bits ist nicht mehr.
Genau, und das wird mal Zeit, weil bisher war das immer noch nur 32 Bit. Das war nicht mehr Universal, sondern das war 32 Bit. Dann switchen die halt auch, und das sollte nochmal ordentlich auch ein bisschen für Speed absorgen beim Wallet-Synchronisieren und so weiter und so fort. Das war wirklich schnallig langsam.
Aber läuft immer noch nicht.
Aber läuft immer noch nicht, ja.
Wegen scheißen User-Interfaces. Vor allem für diese paar Fenster. Das ist ja noch nicht mal ein richtiges GUI.
Und scheiße sieht es auch noch aus. Der Text an den Button sieht immer deplatziert aus.
Willst du das nicht mal machen, Dennis?
Nee, da leg ich mich nicht mit an.
Wieso denn?
Das ist C++ Shit mit Boost drin. Und was weiß ich nicht alles. Das fasse ich nicht an. Ein Rotz ist es vielleicht auch nicht, wenn man Boost toll findet. Was ist denn Boost? Na so C++.
Das ist halt so eine Add-on-Library, die es nicht so richtig in die Standard Library geschafft hat. Schon vor zehn Jahren haben die gesagt, sie würden gerne in die Standard Library mit reinkommen.
Wartet immer noch draußen in der Schlange im Regen.
Aber alle benutzen es. Und das braucht ewig zu bauen.
Die haben ihr eigenes Shredding-Model, ihr eigenes Zeitzeug, ihr habt ihr eigenes alles. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man Bitcoin bauen könnte ohne diese Boost-Scheiße.
Aber du kannst bestimmt einen Podcast alleine über Boost mit Pawel machen.
Mit Pawel sowieso immer lange.
Vielleicht hat ja Boost auch was Tolles, aber wenn man so eine Multi-Plattform, Multi-Alles bauen kann, möglichst Public, ich weiß nicht, ob man da dann auch Boost und QT dran klatschen sollte. Ich bin der Meinung, die sollten ordentliche Lipp machen, möglichst klein, möglichst wenig Abhängigkeiten von anderem Shit. Und dann können die Leute irgendwie Guis drumrum strecken, aber so, das kann noch keiner anfassen.
Also so ist es nicht, sozusagen. Es ist nicht stark gelippt. Ich meine, was ist denn da schon groß? Ist man das noch alles relativ klar definierte Transaktionen, die man da macht?
Ich glaube auch, das Boost ist nicht das Problem, sondern wirklich die Gui, das QT, das soll weg.
Also du willst nicht, Dennis?
Wer soll es dann machen, Dennis?
Soviel zum Thema Bitcoin, es gibt noch keine Entwarnung. Wo wir gerade bei skurrilen Open-Source-Laboris sind.
Was kommt jetzt?
Na ja, nach Apple hat dann wohl auch mal im GNU-Lager jemand nachgeschaut, wie das mit den Zertifikaten ist.
Wahrscheinlich hat er einfach den gleichen Test gemacht, nur woanders?
Nee, es ist ein bisschen anders gelagert. Die haben irgendwann mal, es geht um GNU-TLS, also eine der wenigen weit verbreiteten SSL-Bibliotheken, neben OpenSSL, die halt so in diverser Open-Source-Software, vor allem halt so in dieser GNU-GPL-Landschaft, gerne benutzt wird. Ich kann jetzt gerade keine Produkte aufzählen, wo das drin ist, aber es sind...
Es gibt manche, da kannst du das optional reinkompilieren. Es könnte zum Beispiel auch sein, dass das in Mumble mit drin ist. Das bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher, aber zum Beispiel bei Microsoft-Fair kannst du beim Bauen, beim Configure kannst du ansagen, ob du das mit OpenSSL oder GNU-TLS bauen willst.
Also auf jeden Fall jetzt nicht total esoterisch, sondern wird eben durchaus verwendet. Und es gab wohl so ein Commit, wo sie mal alles so ein bisschen riefritten haben und bei diesem riefreit, ein Fehler unterlaufen, weil sie bei der einen Funktion angenommen haben, dass sie auf dieselbe Art und Weise Fehlermeldungen zurückliefert wie eine andere Funktion. Und deswegen fiel das irgendwie nicht so auf. Also da wurde so ein minus eins anders gedeutet, als es gemeint war. Ja, und dann führte es letzten Endes zu einem ähnlichen Problem. Nicht ganz so dramatisch, glaube ich, wie bei Apple, dass da einfach alles genommen wurde, aber du konntest zumindest Zertifikate so forgen, dass sie eben bei GNU TLS durchkamen. Ja, also wenn man sich mal anschaut, also das ist jetzt ausgerechnet in diesen Bibliotheken und Frameworks, die von so vielen anderen Programmen verwendet werden, aufgetreten sind, ist natürlich doppelt dramatisch. Weil es dann halt jetzt nicht nur ein Programm ist oder so, sondern im Prinzip eine nicht wirklich überschaubare Menge von Software auf einer genauso wenig überschaubaren Anzahl von Maschinen. Und gerade so im Linux...
Hat aber den Vorteil, kannst du das doch wieder zentral fixen.
Ja gut, aber weißt du halt gar nicht, wie viele Server mit weitgehend unangefasster Konfiguration da so vor sich hinticken und so, bis die dann wirklich mal ein Update haben. Ich meine, bei Mac ist es zumindest so, da kommt dann das C9-2, das installierst du und dann ist das Problem auch weg.
Und dafür hast du 33 neue.
Ja, was weiß ich, kann ja sein. Aber naja, gut, so ist es halt jetzt. Aber diese These mit irgendwie Open Source ist ja so sicher, weil da schauen ja so viele Leute drauf, das funktioniert irgendwie weder bei Apple noch im Linux-Lager.
Die hat jetzt zweimal an Glaubwürdigkeit eingepüstet, ne?
Nachhaltig.
Aber was ich komisch fand, also diese Go-To-Fail-Code, der sah schon so merkwürdig aus. Aber dieser GNU-TLS-Code, der war ja fast noch schlimmer. Also mit auch ewig vielen Go-Tos und so. Ich weiß nicht, schreiben diese Krypto-Leute, müssen die so einen Code schreiben? Also mir ist das völlig unklar, dass dieser Code so aussieht.
Du überschreitest da wieder eine Grinse, die seit Jahren aufweicht, aber halt immer noch da ist. Das ist genau das selbe Teil, wenn du dir mal anguckst, so wird es ich Telefon-Quack. Wenn Telefon-Leute anfangen, Software zu schreiben. Und genauso ist das mit dem Krypto. Das sind halt Mathematiker oder so was, die hängen halt in anderen Sphären. Die haben mal im Studium programmieren gelernt, aber so richtig geheuer ist mir das manchmal auch nicht, was ich da lese. Oder du willst auch nicht Elektriker, die jetzt anfangen, Programme zu schreiben, für deine Haussteuerung. Den Code willst du auch nicht sehen.
Du willst aber auch nicht sehen, wie Programmierer verkabeln.
Du willst nicht sehen, aber du musst ja nur in den Baumarkt gehen, da siehst du es überall.
Also ich will die jetzt alle nicht schlecht machen. Die Grenzen verschwimmen auch. Aber die haben halt eben auch andere Ethiken. Hauptsache, das geht. Das muss kein sauberer Code sein, der deinem Informatik-Professor gefällt. Also das Problem wird noch häufiger auftauchen. Gerade im Steuerungsbereich oder da, wo sich eben traditionelle Grenzen von solchen Dingern überschneiden, da ist immer Code-Qualität immer ein bisschen sehr weit unten. Geh doch andersrum. Wie schon gesagt, du möchtest auch keinen Informatiker sehen, der einen Ethernet-Kabel in der Hand hat. Wirklich nicht.
Letztlich, was man halt einfach auch mal wieder sagen muss, ist, dass einfach dieses ganze Zertifikat-basierte Security ist auch einfach ein Problem in sich.
Na ja gut, aber das hat jetzt damit nicht so viel zu tun. Also ich meine, wenn die Library einfach schlecht programmiert ist und nicht das tut, was sie tun soll, ist es egal, ob du jetzt Zertifikate prüfst oder irgendeinen anderen Scheiß, dann funktioniert es halt nicht.
Ja, aber teilweise hast du halt auch so, ich weiß nicht, wir hatten bei Podlove auch so ein Ding, wo dann irgendwie, ja, dann verwendest du halt ein Zertifikat, was halt von irgendeiner Authority gesigned wurde, die aber dann bei den anderen irgendwie nicht anerkannt wird. So ein Firefox wird heutzutage irgendwie mit so einer Myriade an Certifikat-Authorities, die angeblich die Weitheit gefressen haben, ausgeliefert.
Aber nicht CA-Zerts zum Beispiel.
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Ja, nicht CA-Zerts.
Dafür 5000 andere, wahrscheinlich inklusive nordkoreanischer Regierungszertifikat, CA oder sonst was.
Naja, chinesische auf jeden Fall.
Ja, die halt sagen, ja, passt schon. So, das ist im Prinzip.
Und dann kommst du auf ein Kongress und sollst irgendein komisches Zertifikat von irgendeiner komischen Bude da abnicken.
Ja, also, weiß nicht, sehe ich das falsch, aber meiner Meinung nach ist es ein Fehler gewesen, dass man mit diesem ganzen Zertifikatskram, Krypto und Authentication, irgendwie in einem gepackt hat. Ja, also du kriegst quasi Verschlüsselungen im Web nur dann, wenn du beides hast. Du musst halt irgendwie sagen, ja, ich bin hier der Richtige. Ja, dann kannst du auch Krypto machen. Es gibt aber keinen Mechanismus, der sagt, naja, wir machen jetzt hier überhaupt erst mal Krypto. Durch Key Exchange und tralala. Unabhängig jetzt von der, wer bist du eigentlich?
Doch, kannst du machen. Wir machen viele Systeme immer noch. Das ist ja zum Beispiel gerade das Problem, dass die Zertifikate nicht verifizieren. Jetzt rede gar nicht über HTTPS, es gibt ja noch andere TLS-basierte Protokolle. Es ist zum Beispiel so, dass viele Mail-Server, also MTAs, wie Postfix oder XM oder Sendmail, wie sie alle heißen, die sprechen ja gerne mit ihrer Gegenseite Start-TLS. Also machen dann TLS-Layer an, was auch alles schön standardgemäß ist. Aber wenn du da nicht extra noch mal drauf haust oder was reinmachst in die Config, dann nehmen die grundsätzlich das, was drüben da kommt. Die verifizieren die Zertifikat erst mal gar nicht. Die nehmen den Public Key, der da drin ist, was ja eine der Funktionen ist von so einem Zertifikat, nämlich einen Public Key zu transportieren. Und sagen mir ist das scheißegal, weil ich will ja nur einen Key, will ich ja nur sozusagen sauber übermitteln. Und das reicht ja noch aus. Okay, also das geht schon. Ja, du kannst halt einfach sagen, ich scheiße. So ein Zertifikat hat zweierlei Funktionen oder zwei Hauptfunktionen. Nämlich einerseits als Transport-Container für den Public Key zu dienen. Und zweitens eine Identität des Gegenübers zu übermitteln. Das geht ja auch in andere Richtungen. Es gibt ja auch noch kleine Zertifikate. Und wenn du sagst, ich scheiße halt einfach auf den zweiten Teil, mir reicht das aus, wenn ich da so ein Public Key kriege. Und von wo der herkommt, ob der auf dem Self-Sign-Zertifikat steckt oder ob das jetzt ein Veri-Sign Extended Validation Sat für 3000 Dollar ist, mir ist scheißegal, ich will den Public Key haben. Und dann hast du an sich, wenn da jetzt nicht jemand richtig in den Mitteln spielt, sondern nur passiv abhört, hast du eigentlich relativ gute Chancen. Die Krypto da drin ist eigentlich bisher noch ganz okay, wenn du ordentliche Schlüssellängen und so was hast, klar.
Aber im Web?
Im Web kommt es ja natürlich noch drauf an, da willst du jetzt ja extra sehen, ob jetzt die Bank, auf deren Webseite du gerade rumklickst, und deine Pins und Tans eingeht, die auch wirklich ist, die du glaubst. Das heißt, da ist natürlich das schon spannender.
Ja gut, aber wenn ich jetzt...
Aber es gibt andere, da interessiert dich das nicht, wenn du jetzt einfach nur sagst, im Mail-Server machen die Routing ja nach anderen Kriterien.
Ja, aber ich kann ja einen Browser gegenüber, nicht meine Webseite mit, ja ich mach hier mal Verschlüsselung, aber ich hab halt keine spezielle Identität.
Noch, machst du ein Self-Sign-Certificate da?
Ja, dann kriegst du Error.
Ja, aber dann sagt der User, ich will trotzdem noch, hast du eine verschlüsselte Verbindung, und die ist nicht besser und nicht schlechter, als die von Verisign.
Ja, aber sie erzeugt halt immer erstmal einen Fehler.
Ja, aber nochmal, das betrifft nicht die Verschlüsselung, das betrifft jetzt der User. Ja, aber das betrifft nicht die Verschlüsselung. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Ich kenne zum Beispiel Industriekunden von einer Firma, wo ich Consulting für mache. Die haben sich für einen dusseligen Citrix-Server, wo sie ihre Mode access für ihre eigenen Mitarbeiter und für Fremdzonen haben sich ein extended, validated Verisign-Certificat für ein paar tausend Dollar im Jahr gekauft. Und ich so, okay, warum macht er jetzt nur ein 1024-Bit-Schlüssel da rein? Das ist halt irgendwie, weil denen geht es eigentlich nur um die Transport-Security. Vertrauen, dass sie selber, sie haben es schon, die brauchst du jetzt nicht, diese grüne, weißt du, dieses extended validation certificate sind die, die dir oben nicht nur ein Schloss hinmalen, sondern das auch noch schön in so einem grünen Kasten einbauen. Mit Feuerwerk. Hängt von deinem Browser an, aber das muss dann in einem grünen Kasten sein. Das ist das, was die Banken sich kaufen, so ein Ding. Ja, selbst bei den Zertifikaten, die dir für teuer Geld kauft, gibt es noch eine Zwei-Klassen-Gesellschaft. Da kannst du mal irgendeine HTTPS-Seite zum Beispiel mit irgendeiner Bank vergleichen, wie Sparkasse.
Ja, wir gucken, ob das grün ist, ja.
Warum machen die Browser-Hersteller das eigentlich mit?
Da ist ein grüner Kasten drum herum, zack! Weil sie damit Geld verdienen.
Die Browser-Hersteller? Apple kriegt Geld, welche Zertifikate sie da aufnehmen?
Alle kriegen Geld dafür, dass sie die Zertifikate da aufnehmen. Das wird dann nach einmal durch so Industrie-Konsortien durchgechannelt. Es gibt nämlich so ein Konsortium, wo diese ganzen CAs und die Browser-Hersteller alle drin sitzen, so ein Industrie-Konsortium, wo die sich dann solche Sachen verabreden. Und natürlich dient das alles immer nur dafür, dass der Kunde viel sicherer im Internet sein kann. Deswegen sind an solche Sachen dann auch besonders strenge Zertifizierungsregeln gebunden. Da musst du nämlich Handelsregister-Auszüge hinschicken und so. Und dann rufen sie nochmal an. Das ist dann besonders sicher. Und dann kriegst du halt so ein EV-Zertifikat und dann hast du so einen grünen Kasten um deine Dinger herum.
So eine Testadresse hat ja auch jemand gerade im Chat gepostet, aber die heißt anders als die, die du hast und deine sah auch doof aus. Geh mal zu ssltools.net Weiß nicht, das hab ich hier von Clemens bekommen. Geh mal zu ssltools.net Geh mal hin. Das ist genau gleich, wie dit nun schick.
Dann machen wir da jetzt Web-Server-Test.
Hast du das andere noch nicht gesehen?
Dann lassen wir erstmal fertig werden. Mal gucken.
Mal sehen, was ssl-tools zu meiner Testseite sagt. Ja, aber das Qualys Zeug macht noch viel mehr Tests. Was Qualys noch netterweise mit dazu macht, ist, dass sie Browser simulieren. Und zwar so bis hin zu Windows.
Das wird mal kurz sagen, wovon wir reden.
Ja, sag doch mal, wovon wir reden.
Das ist ja nicht im Ansatz so schick, wie das von Qualys. Der ist ja noch nicht fertig.
Ach so, das dauert so lange.
Ja, weil der simuliert all möglichen Scheiß. Der macht tausend Request dagegen.
Der macht da jetzt so eine ganze Batterie von verschiedenen Checks und danach kommt er irgendwie mit so einem fertigen Ergebnis.
Und der sagt dir, ob auch noch der Browser von Anno Tuff auf deinem Windows 95 das auch noch mit SSL machen würde oder ob der abstürzen würde und so weiter und so fort. Oder deine Java-Library.
Wir sollten mal kurz erklären, wovon wir reden. Also wir reden von Webseiten, die jetzt SSL testen. Darauf wollte ich noch mal zu sprechen kommen, weil so viel darüber geredet worden ist mit ja, die Zertifikate werden ja nicht akzeptiert, weil jetzt irgendwie Gotofell da drin ist. Wenn wir SSL haben, dann haben wir hier die große Verheißung, weil irgendeine nordkoreanische Bude gesagt hat, das ist schon alles irgendwie in Ordnung. Jetzt ist Verschlüsselung einfach nicht gleich Verschlüsselung. Wenn du eben tatsächlich die Verbindung machst von deinem Client zu deinem Server, dann handeln die beiden eben verschiedene Parameter aus. Manche einigen sich unter anderem auf Verschlüsselung, Cyphers und Key-Längen und ich weiß gar nicht, was da jetzt alles noch mit reinkommt. Kannst du das mal ausführen, Clemens? Weil ich kenne mich da nicht aus. Was wird da jetzt ausgehandelt und was da jetzt alles relevant ist.
Es gibt tausend Parameter, die da ausgehandelt werden. Es gibt ja zum Beispiel verschiedene Art und Weisen, den eigentlichen Session-Schlüssel auszutauschen. Weil die Schlüssel, die in den Zertifikaten drin stehen, zum Beispiel die Private Keys, die werden ja nicht zum Verschlüsseln des eigentlichen Datenstroms benutzt. Der Datenstrom wird mit einem symmetrischen Zeifer gemacht und für den wird halt ein temporärer, zufälliger Schlüssel erzeugt. Und nur der wird halt über diese Public-Key-Verfahren ausgetauscht. Der Hintergrund ist der, dass diese Public-Key-Verfahren rechenpowermäßig unglaublich teuer sind und man sozusagen das ganze Web gar nicht betreiben könnte, wenn man die Daten wirklich echt mit RSA verschlüsseln würde. Also generiert man einen temporären Schlüssel für einen schnellen symmetrischen Zeifer, den berühmten RC4, den es ja schon länger gibt, habt ihr alles schon von gehört, oder AIS oder Blowfish oder wie auch immer solche Dinge.
Die Enigma hat das übrigens auch schon gemacht. Transportwegverschlüsselung. Und der Schlüssel wurde dann mit dem Tagesschlüssel verschlüsselt.
Also wie gesagt, es wird allen Teilen immer wieder in dem ganzen Krypto-Zoo gemacht, dass du sozusagen einen One-Time-Patch-Schlüssel generierst, einen zufälligen, den musst du halt nur irgendwie rüber kriegen. Ja, und da gibt es halt Schlüssellaustauschverfahren, mehr oder weniger Schlauer. Und es gibt dieses schöne Diffi-Helmen-Verfahren, was ich eigentlich sehr, sehr schick finde. Was wie gesagt relativ neu ist noch, also im Vergleich zu anderen Verfahren, die es so gibt, ist total simpel, aber die haben irgendwie keine Ahnung, bis in die 90er gebraucht, bis sie sich das ausgeknuspert haben.
Diffi-Helmen?
Mhm, das ist relativ jung im Vergleich zu dem anderen Zeugs.
So, sag doch mal hier... Gut, ich biete ihm auch ein paar Webseiten eures Vertrauens.
Facebook.
Na, nimm nochmal testschrümpel.de.
Das ist aber unfair. pfefe.de Gibt es das mit HTTPS?
Ja, sicher?
Und wenn der jetzt nicht einen A-Plus hat, dann... Das wissen wir auch nicht.
Also Facebook hat auch nur A-.
Aber immerhin.
netzpolitik.org hat auch A-.
Jetzt muss man allerdings dazu sein, wenn ihr euch mal genau die Bewertungskriterien anguckt von diesem SSL-Labs-Test, da fließen auch so Sachen ein, wie kompatibel ist denn das eigentlich? Das ist relativ einfach. Oder sagen wir, solche Parameter fließen, denn nicht schwer genug ein. Du kannst zum Beispiel dir einen SSL-Server bauen, der nur mit neuesten Algorithmen bestückt ist. Der kriegt da sofort eine relativ hohe Bewertung auf dem Ding. Das ist aber zu nicht mehr kompatibel. Also in der Handshake-Simulation, wo die so keine Ahnung, so drei Dutzend verschiedene Browser oder Systeme simulieren, oder so, was fällt da hinten da? Siehst du zum Beispiel, da Internet Explorer 6 oder Internet Explorer 8 gibt es den Protokoll aus High-Five-Suit-Mismatch. Da kann man einfach sagen, das interessiert mich nicht. Solche User, die mit solchen Browsern ankommen, brauche ich nicht unterstützen auf meinem System. Kannste machen, aber wie gesagt... Ja, weiß ich nicht. Also ich hab jetzt mal meinen so hingetunt, dass die alle noch gehen und dass ich trotzdem noch einen Apache 2.2 benutzen kann. Aber richtig geiles CCCDE. Ja, da kommen sie aber jetzt wieder, da mauern sie jetzt wieder rum, dass ihnen ein Zertifikat nicht gefällt, weil das wieder Self-Signed ist oder von CACert kommt oder so. Man muss sich das genauer angucken, was das Ergebnis unten ist. Beim Key Exchange unten bei der Cypher Strengths haben sie relativ gute Bewertungen, aber wenn du jetzt oben nicht ankommst mit einer von den Standard CAs, dann bist du natürlich abgestraft.
Aber wozu brauchst du das auf CCCDE? Da kann sich keiner einloggen, das ist ja nur Static Content.
Wie Tim sagt, es gibt eine Warnung auf dem Browser und das will er ja vermeiden. Weil wie gesagt, für die Krypto HTTPS auf CCCDE.
Warum ist das eingeführt worden? Ja, um der Welt klarzumachen, wie wichtig das ist, überhaupt erstmal zu verschlüsseln.
Dann machen sie so ein kaputtes HTTPS.
Ist ja nicht kaputt.
Das ist ja Self-Scient. Gleichzeitig wollen wir auch sagen, wie scheiße das ist, wenn du überall dein Herz kaufen musst.
Von den Protokollen her sieht das ganz ordentlich aus. Was?
Was sie damit der Welt sagen, ist, wir kriegen es auch nicht hin. Wenn du diese Websites aufmachst, dann kriegst du eine Fehlermeldung.
Das ist jetzt nicht so schwer. Du musst dich mit dem Thema schon auseinandersetzen, damit du die Terminologie verstehst, aber der Rest ist dann mehr oder weniger gesunder Menschenverstand.
Er hat ja auch die ganzen EES alle rausgekickt.
Bei FIFA hat er auch TLS 1.2, das ist alles schick, aber er hat natürlich auch einen Self-Signed, glaube ich.
Aber die anderen sind alle grün bis zum Anschlag hinten. Das ist ordentlich. Wenn du bei FIFA da einhackst.
Das ist halt nur die Sache mit dem Zertifikat. Nein, nein, das ist mir jetzt auch bewusst. Nur, ich finde es halt einfach schade, dass es im Web nicht möglich ist, einfach diesen, ich beweise dir wer du bist, Teil wegzulassen und der Rest ist okay. Und der Browser akzeptiert es trotzdem und zeigt es bloß anders an. Klar geht es, aber es kommt halt immer mit Panik, Fenster.
Ja, ein paar Kost und Kroh mit dem Schlagstock-Polizisten, der gleich sagt, ne, ne, stopp.
Ja, aber ein Man in the Middle ist jetzt nicht unheard of im Netz. Also besonders seit dem letzten halben Jahr ist es nicht unheard of. Und ohne Zertifikat, keine Ahnung. Also wenn du einen beliebigen Man in the Middle machen kannst, dann ist es auch...
Da gehen sie jetzt inzwischen dran an diese Man in the Middle-Nummer. Da gehen sie jetzt inzwischen dran, da ist die ITF auch länger im Spiel. Letztes Mal, als ich hier in der Sendung war vor vier Wochen, hat sich da das schon erwähnt mit diesen zusätzlichen Mechanismen, dass man jetzt seine Zertifikate noch absichert über DNS. Wo du natürlich die DNS selber wieder absichern musst über DNSSEC, wo du jetzt zum Beispiel sagen kannst, das Zertifikat auf meiner Webseite ist, hat ihr fertigst von der und der Institution zu kommen. Und nicht von irgendjemanden. Also nicht von China Telekom CA, sondern bitte von der CA, die ich auch genommen habe. Das heißt, das Thema wird angenommen. Gerade auf dem IETF-Meeting in London gibt es diese Dane Working Group, D-A-N-E, die sich intensiv mit dem Thema befassen. Und da tut sich auch was. Es gibt auch langsam immer mehr Leute, die das implementieren. Also das wird noch eine Weile dauern, bis das rum ist. Aber die versuchen da noch was zu retten, würde ich damit sagen.
C-A-Z hat Org, hat auch ein F. Protokoll-Support ist auf jeden Fall weniger als...
Ich meine, bei facebook.com wird... Was wird denn hier angemeckert, dass Forward Secrecy nicht unterstützt wird? Was muss man denn da einbauen?
Also was macht denn das? Die Idee ist, dass man das so macht, dass wenn man jetzt kein Man in the Middle hat, dass der dir später auch nichts mehr nützt, wenn du da den mal den Key beschlagnahmst oder sonst irgendwie klaust oder sowas.
So wie OTR das schlecht macht.
Genau, das erzeugt nochmal einen temporären Zwischenkey erst mal.
Genau, und den sie halt eben auch so austauschen, dass wenn du nicht im Moment jetzt Man in the Middle machst, sondern den Verkehr nur aufzeichnen ist passiv. Dass dir das nichts nützt, selbst wenn du später einen der beiden Keys dir greifst. Also wenn du hinterher hingehst und sagst, ich geh jetzt mal zu Facebook und beschlagnahm mal deren Private Key, was ja so eine NSA durchaus erst mal tun könnte. Und dann können sie sozusagen alle etwas aufgezeichnet haben, das ist ja bekannt auch durch die Snowden Veröffentlichung, dass die Dienste alle etwas mitlesen können, jetzt mitlesen und analysieren, alles was sie nicht mitlesen können derzeit, weil es verschlüsselt ist, dass sie das aufzeichnen und irgendwo hin speichern für den Fall, dass sie das irgendwann mal auseinanderfleddern können. Das hat Tradition bei denen, weil da hatten sie schon mal Spaß mit, da hatten sie nach dem Krieg schon mal Spaß mit, weil zum Beispiel die Russen haben sich mal getraut, aus politischen Gründen wurden da mal ein paar Kryptologen umgebracht und dann hatten sie eine Zeit lang kein vernünftiges Kryptozeugen und haben sie alte Schüssel wiederverwendet. Und das haben die Amis dann genutzt, um alte Telegramme, die sie hatten oder die sie aufgezeichnet hatten, dann nochmal wieder auseinanderzufleddern. Also es hat Tradition bei denen, dass sie sagen, wir zeichnen alles auf, was wir nicht verstehen, für den Fall, dass wir es irgendwann mal verstehen. Und Perfect Forward Seekersy soll explizit das verhindern. Weil es denen um Kompatibilität geht. Der Facebook ist nicht an der Security seiner User interessiert. Der Facebook ist daran interessiert, dass seine User ihre Daten da abliefern, egal wie unsicher. Damit verdienen nämlich ihr Geld. Und wenn da auch nur ein halber uralter kreuzkranker Browser dabei ist, der sagen würde, das geht hier alles nicht, dann verlieren sie wieder 20 User, deren Daten sie nicht kriegen. Also sind die auf Kompatibilität getrimmt und nicht auf Sicherheit.
Das ist doch alles furchtbar.
Das ist nicht furchtbar. Man muss einfach nur verstehen, warum machen die Leute das? Oder was gibt es da für Parameter da dran? Das SSL hat Facebook auch nicht freiwillig angemacht. Das haben sie angemacht, weil alle das tun und weil genügend Leute rumgemault haben. Aber nicht, weil sie jetzt tierisch Bock darauf haben, das zu machen. Also haben sie das so harmlos wie möglich angemacht, damit immer noch alle User bei ihnen drauf rumklicken können.
Schön mit 1024 Bit-Key ansauen.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist auch nicht notwendigerweise State of the Art, aber das ist der alte VeriSyn Class 3 Public Key. Das alte Ding, das ist ein Wekey. Aber der selber von Facebook, aber die haben sogar einen Wildcard-Key, 2048, ja, kann man machen.
GitHub hat ja da so einen fetten Blogpost gemacht zu ihrer SSL-Infrastruktur und dass sie jetzt halt auch dieses Forward-Secrecy und alles Mögliche, was fancy ist, da einbauen. Und da kommt ja das SSL-Labs gar nicht mit klar, ne? Der Blogpost war auf jeden Fall ganz cool dazu.
Jetzt alles sicher.
Die GitHub-Jungs, die machen schon sehr viel, sehr richtig. Das muss man eh wirklich lassen.
So Clemens, wo wir jetzt sowieso schon dabei sind, dann erzähl doch mal ein bisschen, wie es in London war.
Verhältnismäßig ordentliches Wetter. Für die Londoner Verhältnisse. Ja, also warum war ich da? Ich fand wieder mal ein IETF-Meeting statt. Jeder in unregelmäßigen Abständen dahin. Meistens aber, um dort selber auch ein Netz zu bauen vor Ort für die Teilnehmer. Da hatten wir diesmal in London so knapp 1400 Leute oder so. Muss man mal gucken, 1300-1400 Leute. Und dann fängt man halt eben an, so ein Konferenzcenter oder so ein Hotel da eben umzubauen. Dieser Job hat Höhen und Tiefen, muss man sagen. Was heißt denn eigentlich Job?
Was ist denn deine Rolle da, wenn du dahin fährst? Hast du da eigentlich irgendeine Aufgabe?
Bist du da Freelancer? Ich werde da eingeladen von Leuten, die ich schon länger kenne, die Veranstaltungen machen, die sagen, wir machen hier das Ding, willst du nicht kommen mithelfen? Ich bin da sozusagen Volontier, die zahlen schon die Reisekosten und so was, aber ich kriege da jetzt kein Geld dafür. Wir sind eigentlich so ein Häufchen von Universalisten, die da alle Möche machen. Da wird ja jede Menge Infrastruktur aufgebaut, aber jeder hat halt so sein Spezialgebiet und meint es halt eben zum Beispiel Telcos anbrüllen. Anbrüllen? Deswegen suchen die sich halt eben einen Deutschen dafür. Also nicht notwendig, aber man muss schon ein bisschen mehr Nerven haben. Also wenn ihr alle glaubt, wenn eure Sorgen mit DSL-Anschlüssen zu Hause oder so, das würde der Industrie nicht passieren, oder bei Großkunden oder sonst irgendwas, wäre das nicht der Fall, kann ich euch beruhigen. Die sind genauso. British Telecom war da der Sponsor. Wir haben jetzt ein bisschen was anderes drauf gemacht. Ich hab letztes Jahr angefangen, nicht erst vor Ort rauszufinden, dass die Leitungen nicht so sind wie bestellt, sondern ich nehme jetzt immer so einen kleinen Edge-Router und schick den vorne weg. Und wir haben einen Team, der gerade in Cambridge an seinem Doktor bastelt, dem hab ich das Ding zugeschickt, der hat gesagt, setz dich da mal in den Zug, fahr mal nach London, steck das mal dran, das war 14 Tage vor dem eigentlichen Meeting. Und wo die Circuits von BT schon da sein sollten, hab ich so einen kleinen Edge-Router fertig gemacht und den haben wir dann an zwei Gigabit-Leitungen von British Telecom dran gehängt. Und dann mit voll BGP-Peering. Und dann eben mal so geguckt, was passiert, wenn man halt eben so Adressraum annonciert. Da gibt es interessante Beobachtungen dazu, also kann man ein paar nennen. Zum Beispiel hab ich extra aufgeschrieben, die Chinesen. Ich bin fest der Meinung, dass diese Scans, die da stattfinden aus China, also wo nach offenen SSH-Ports gesucht wird oder offenen Remote-Desktop-Verbindungen oder sonst irgendwas, dass die nicht bloß von irgendwelchen gekaperten PC stattfinden, sondern dass da Systeme hinter ist. Würde ich deswegen behaupten, weil immer dann, wenn ich mal einen neuen Adressraum annonziere per BGP, also IP-Adressraum, IPv4-Adressraum, wurde gemerkt, IPv4-Adressraum, bekannt gebe dem Internet, so hallo, den gibt's jetzt hier. Und den gab's vorher nicht, oder den gab's monatelang nicht. Dauert nur wenige Sekunden und schon wird nach SSH und Remote Desktop Ports gescannt, und zwar aus China. Das heißt, die Leute, die das machen, die lesen auch sozusagen die BGP-Announcements mit. Ja, und denken, oh, ein neues Netz. Gleich mal dran lecken.
Das ist ja der beste Moment, um noch offene SSHs oder was auch immer zu finden, weil die Firma anscheinend berichtet sich gerade ein, ein neues Netz ist ja alles noch frisch, der Admin ist vielleicht noch nicht fertig mit einem Sicherheitspaket, der noch nicht alle installiert und dann schnell mal rübergeguckt drauf bleibt.
Also es ist jetzt nur eine Beobachtung, ich hab keine Beweise dafür, aber du annoncierst ein neues Netz und du kannst wirklich deinen Wireshark drauf laufen lassen innerhalb von Sekunden. Brrrrratz! Okay, dann gibt es immer noch so Sachen mit dieser Geolocation, auch immer wieder ein spannendes Thema. Das Netz, was wir dort verwenden, also wir verwenden verschiedene Netze dort für diese IETF-Veranstaltung, die aus verschiedenen Gegenden dieser Welt kommen. Und das Netz ist unglaublich lahm, obwohl es überall vermerkt ist, dass es ein Netz ist, das durch die Gegend zieht, und eigentlich auch allen wichtigen Leuten klargemacht wird. Es gibt auch extra Kontakte zu Ackermai und so was. Aber ansonsten ist das Netz unglaublich lahm und hinkt immer diesen IETF-Geschichten hinterher. Das heißt, wenn du also in Berlin bist, glaubt die Welt immer noch, du wärst in Prag. Und jetzt, wo wir in London waren, glaubten sie alle, wir wären irgendwie in Genf oder so. Also das ist irgendwie sehr lustig, was dann manchmal obskuren Situationen führt, wenn du halt so YouTube-Videos abrufst oder so, oder auf Google-Seiten klickst, die dann plötzlich komische Sprachen mit dir sprechen. Das war wohl besonders lustig, da war ich dann nicht dabei, aber nach einer der letzten Meetings im letzten Jahr oder so in Peking, da war dann danach erstmal, die Teilnehmer googelten, weil er nicht so gebrochen war, da mussten immer erstmal von Hand die Sprache richtig einstellen.
Da waren wir ja alle Russen.
Die Zeitzone war doch irgendwie an der Westküste für ein Amiland.
Ja, die Industrie braucht auch echt... Du musst es auch mal zusätzlich noch machen, wenn du jetzt noch Access Points, also ein Wireless-Net durch die Gegend schleppst, mit Access Points, die mal hier und da und dort waren. Das ist auch sehr, sehr lustig. Wir haben es jetzt größtenteils bei Google weg, weil wir auch Leute von Google im Team haben, bei dem es auch immer wieder sehr lustig ist, weil man sich dann abends ja auch mal so beim Essen oder so, oder nebenbei, während man auf irgendwas wartet, dann mal versucht, so ein bisschen den Google-Leuten was zu entlocken. Ja, aber die trinken alle nicht. Aber wir haben jetzt was rausgefunden. Einen von denen kann man mit Zucker voll stopfen. Das heißt, wir haben den mit Kuchen bestöckt, um mal so ein paar Google-Geheimnisse zu entlocken. War sehr lustig. Aber egal. Ja, und wie gesagt, ich mach jetzt so, dass ich dann so einen kleinen Router vorne wegschicke und erst mal diese ganzen Geolocation, Peering-Sachen und so was versuche vorab zu checken. Das heißt, wenn man denn da aufläuft, ein paar Tage vor dem eigentlichen Event, und wir dann die großen Juniper-Router da dran stecken, dann ist sozusagen, dann sind die Leitungen schon ordentlich durchgeblasen und eingenordet.
Wie viele Leute nehmen denn teil an so einem Meeting?
Ich sag ja, so 13 bis 14 Hundert Leute.
Aber ich meine, das ist doch nicht wie auf einem Kongress, dass die da alle irgendwie zocken und Fall-Server aufbauen.
Also es gibt ja auch keine Hosting-Center, wo die Leute ihre Fallserver abschmeißen. Die arbeiten so. Die sind so getunet. Außerdem sind sie gewohnt. Das ist eigentlich albern. Aber die normalen Netze in den Hotels oder in den Konferenzcentern reichen nicht aus. Üblicherweise ist es so, dass die Hotelnetze schon zusammenbrechen, wenn sich die Leute nur anstellen, um abends einzuchecken. Weil dann laufen halt eben paarhundert Leute auf, die stehen alle in der Lobby oder beim Check-in und checken natürlich mit ihren Handys oder Tabletten oder wie auch immer, während sie in der Schlange stehen, ihre Mails oder sonst irgendwas. Und dann wartet schon mal mit dem Hotelnetz, weil das können die nicht ab.
Und da hat es Leute, die schon Internet gemacht haben, als es WWW noch nicht gab, oder?
Ja, und die arbeiten wirklich damit. Also die arbeiten massiv, kollaborativ, implementieren auch, die sitzen, also man muss dazusagen, gibt diese Meetings, diese recht formalen Meetings, hatte ich auch schon mal du erzählt, wo dann so eine Agenda abgearbeitet wird, und wo dann auch gebrummt wird oder gesummt wird, ob einem das jetzt gefällt oder nicht. Aber was auch so richtig Arbeit, wo richtig Arbeit gemacht wird, wo sich Leute immer wieder finden, das ist dann eigentlich eher so etwas wie ein Klassentreffen von irgendwelchen Leuten, die sich dann dreimal im Jahr treffen, um irgendwas zu machen, sind so abends an einer Bar oder auf irgendwelchen Hotelzimmern oder in irgendwelchen Ecken zwischen den Konferenzräumen oder so was, sitzen sie dann mit ihren Laptops und hacken dann so dritt, viert, fünft oder so weiter in irgendein Projekt rum oder hacken an irgendeinen Standard oder an irgendeine Implementation.
Und dann brauchen die einfach metallisches, scharfkantiges Netz.
Ja, was sie nicht brauchen, ist diese komische Hotel-Nattkacke mit dem Portal und klicken sie hier, wenn sie die Bedingungen akzeptieren und diesen ganzen Scheiß.
Das kann ich nicht verstehen.
Das geht nicht. Genau, man will einfach, dass es irgendwie...
Das muss einfach nur gehen. Das muss nicht fancy sein. Es gibt auch ein paar Sub... Wir machen auch Netze wie irgendwie auch auf dem Kongress. Wir haben auch zum Beispiel ein Nut64-Netz. Das heißt, es ist also ein Netz, da ist nur IPv6 drauf. Und dann mit so einer carrier-grade Nut-Kiste, wie sie auch dann eingesetzt wird, um halt dann die Leute mal sozusagen eat your own dog food. Ja, sozusagen ihr habt das alle beschlossen, das soll so sein. Jetzt probiert ihr das mal fällig selber aus. Machen denn auch auf jedem Meeting, wo wir gemerkt haben, 13, 14 Hundert Leute, machen das auch so sechs oder acht. Und es gibt zum Beispiel Firmen, die sich immer noch sehr toll damit blamieren. Zum Beispiel die Firma Apple, wenn du nämlich das mit einem iPhone machst oder so was, oder mit einem iPad, in dieses Netz, dein Browser geht und deine ganzen Dienste gehen eigentlich auch, nur keiner von den Apple-Diensten. Weil die ganzen Apple Apps schauen offensichtlich, da müssen jetzt hier die Apple-Entwickler was zu sagen, gibt es bestimmt irgendein Framework oder so was, was das macht, die schauen auf das Interface drauf und wenn das Interface keine IPv4-Adresse hat, sind die qua Definition nicht mit dem Internet verbunden. Das heißt, iMessage sagt, ich habe kein Netz, es gibt kein Netz. iTunes-Store sagt, es gibt kein Netz. Facetime sagt, es gibt kein Netz. Obwohl Browser und so was funktioniert alles. Mail geht auch, aber die ganzen Apple-Dienste selber sagen, wenn das nicht V4 ist, ist das kein Jim Beam, dann nehmen sie das nicht. Sie glauben halt einfach noch nicht da drauf. Man könnte es ja ausprobieren, man könnte jetzt einfach sagen, ich versuche mal mit einem Server zu connecten und wenn das nicht klappt, dann kann ich immer noch an den Netz zweifeln. Aber wie gesagt, aufs Interface gucken. Wenn das Interface keine V4-Adresse hat, dann gibt es kein Netz. Das ist einfach von Anno Tuff. Das ist einfach blamabel für Apple, finde ich.
Schlimm.
Aber egal, sowas kann man dann auch ausprobieren und so, aber es wird da halt eben gearbeitet und die nutzen wirklich das Netz. Was wir meistens auch noch machen, haben wir auch gemacht in London, weil das Konferenzzentrum war auch das Hotel selber, ist, dass wir dann das Hotelnetz noch mit übernehmen. Das ist manchmal mit mehr oder weniger Kooperation verbunden. Diesmal hatten wir mehr Kooperationen, aber das war ein Hotel mit über 1000 Zimmern oder so. Keine Ahnung, wie viele 100 APs, die wir rumzuhängen haben und in welchen Gängen und so. Die kannst du jetzt nicht alle austauschen. Das heißt, wir nehmen die Physik, die Access Points und die Switches und die Verkabelung von denen, machen aber, sagen ja, euer Router und euer Tollet Login Portal, lass mal stecken, wir machen jetzt unseren Router dran, dann gibt es da V4 und V6 auf dem Netz und das ist gut. Das hilft uns, wie gesagt, nicht mit der Radioabdeckung innerhalb des Ladens, aber immerhin, wenn du denn mal eine Radio-Connection hast, dann hast du auch wenigstens ein ordentliches Netz dahinter. Und ja, das ist ganz lustig. So, was gibt es da noch? Hab ich mal auf die Liste geschrieben. Ach ja, es wird ja immer wieder mal so gefragt, auch letztes Jahr, als wir diese Netzneutralitätsdiskussion hatten und so weiter und so fort, dass wenn ich jetzt so ein ISP mache, was kostet das alles? Wie ist denn das jetzt eigentlich? Wo kriegt ihr jetzt das Internet her, um das mal selber zu verteilen, wenn ich mein eigenes DSL-Netz baue oder so? Und da ist mir was untergekommen, als ich das mit den Kollegen auch mal diskutiert habe. Es gibt ein Internet-Peering-Playbook von einem Typen, der sich da seit sehr, sehr vielen Jahren damit befasst. Da kann man nachlesen, wie da abgerechnet wird, was sowas kostet und wie diese ganzen politischen Spielchen da ablaufen. Und da wird auch sehr viel gesoffen, wohl angeblich.
Ja, also im CCC gab es ja auch schon einige, die so in diesen Kreisen da gearbeitet haben. Meinst du, Kaptur? Ja, auch schon davor. Die haben auch mal von diesen Peering-Partys und so erzählt und das klang wie so ein LSD-getriebenes Hippiefestival oder sowas, oder vielleicht MDMA, irgendwas sowas.
Weil auch mal spannend ist, einfach jetzt mal so aktueller.
Das ist sehr Peering-kompatibler, genau.
Aktueller Preis für Internet auf dieser Ebene, wenn man so sozusagen der Großhandelspreis ist im Mittel ungefähr knapp unter einem Dollar pro Megabit. Kannst du auch noch billiger kriegen, kannst du auch teurer kriegen, aber so Pima Dorm und...
Welche Zeit einheit?
Einen Monat.
Ein Megabit pro Monat...
Ein Dollar.
Direktional-Connectivity im Backbone-Netz.
Ja, die gibt's aber im Minimum, was du kaufen kannst, ist ein G. Also musst du dann schon 1000 Dollar hinlegen für deinen Gigabit. Aber das ist immer symmetrisch, da gibt's keine... Asymmetrie gibt's da nur hinten zu dir zum End-User raus.
Reden wir jetzt von Traffic oder von Connectivity?
Nee, von Traffic. Und das wird halt aber...
Das wird in Gigabit gemessen.
Ja, das wird die Abrechnungsmethode, die übliche Abrechnungsmethode, also so genannte Percentil-Regelung, üblich sind zum Beispiel 95 Prozent. Geht so, du machst an deine Leitung, zu deinem Peering-Partner, machst du ein Tacho dran, beziehungsweise machst zwei Tachos dran, wenn du jetzt wirklich Geld dafür übertun willst. Also für jede Richtung Tacho. Und das heißt, diesen Tacho liest du alle fünf Minuten ab und schreibst dir den Wert in irgendeine Datenbank. Dann am Ende des Monats, also wenn du abrechnen willst, dann sortierst du diese Daten, also sozusagen die Tachowerte von höchsten nach niedrigsten und schmeißt die obersten fünf Prozent weg. Und der Wert, der dann kommt, multipliziert mit dem Megabit pro Geld, kostet der Preis, was das denn kostet. So, und dann kannst du halt eben, was üblich ist, wie gesagt, das Minimum, was du heutzutage kaufen kannst, ist ein G. Was inzwischen sehr, sehr üblich ist, ist 10G oder N mal 10G. Und was jetzt, wie gesagt, auch gerne mal gemacht wird, sind jetzt schon mal 100G oder sowas. Also das sind die eigentlichen Leitungen. Und dann guckst du auf den Tacho, wenn du überhaupt gegenseitig abrufst. Also das nur mal für die Leute, die gerne wissen wollten, wie es so weit geht. Den Rest kann man in dem Buch nachlesen. Den Link zum Buch hat Tim gerade in den Chat geschmissen. Ich hoffe, dass die Show-Nutze doch aufsammeln und irgendwo hinschreiben. Also für all die Leute, die immer fragen, was kostet denn das? Wer kann ich denn ein ISP werden? Hm, könnt ihr alles nachlesen, in diesem tollen Buch. Dann gibt es noch so ein paar andere Sachen, so kleine Anekdoten. Also man müsste jetzt meinen, dass dieses Ding dreimal im Jahr stattfindet. Und diese 13-1400 Leute, da ist ein nicht unerheblicher Zoo dabei, der taucht auch auf allen Meetings auf. Also könnte man sich überlegen, wenn man das eine Weile macht, waren die schon mal irgendwo auf der Welt. Aber zu jedem Meeting gibt es eine Mailing-Liste, wo diese ganzen Attendees drauf sind und sich gegenseitig mit irgendwelchen tollen Fragen beschäftigen. Wie zum Beispiel, ist denn der Honig in England jetzt echter Bienenhonig oder ist der mit Zuckerwasser gemacht? Oder ein Thema, das sie wahnsinnig aufgeregt hat, ist ja festgestellt, da sind ja auch Steckdosen an der Wand. Und was macht denn jetzt meine Tochter, die ich mitgebracht habe, die ihren hair straightener aus USA da nicht reinplaggen kann? Und du denkst echt, hallo, das sind Engineered, die waren schon auf der Welt, die müssten doch schon mal kapiert haben, dass es woanders anderen Strom gibt, woanders andere Stecker und die fallen jedes Mal da vom Glauben ab. Oder, ah nee, das musst du dann da anzubscriben, das war nicht mehr zu ertranken. Was schön war, weil ich jetzt gerade noch so schön im Räderfluss bin, weil ich mache, zieh dich jetzt auch durch, damit der nämlich gehen kann, bevor es zum nächsten Bitcoin-Thema kommt. Damit Tim jetzt mal anfängt ein bisschen zu weinen. Ich hab ja gesagt, ich guck mich mal jetzt um, was so die aktuelle Mobilfunkgeschichte in UK da so macht und wer da einen ordentlichen Preis hat. Und ich hab mir mal wieder von meinem Lieblingsprovider 3, den ich auch in Schweden gerne benutze oder in Österreich, die gibt's auch in UK und die bieten dir für 15 Pfund im Monat LTE an Unlimited. Da kommen die Tränen, ich seh's. 15 Pfund. Jetziger Ratio ist 1,20 Euro für das Pfund. Unlimited. Und zwar übrigens Unlimited auch dahingehend, dass sie sagen, wenn du Wolk machen willst, mach doch. Oder wenn du tättern willst.
Also auch unrestricted.
Okay, die sind jetzt in der LTE-Abdeckung noch nicht ganz so weit wie in Schweden. Nee, aber in London hat das sehr gut funktioniert. Und selbst wenn du auf 3G zurückfällst, ist ja egal. Du kannst ja auch mit ein paar Megabits in 3G leben, wenn du da ordentlich mit Wolken kannst und so weiter. Ich hab die ganze Zeit gefacetime'ed. Dort, also nicht die ganze Zeit, aber wenigstens gefacetime'ed haben wir nach Hause oder so. Und das hab ich immer gerne über das Netz von denen gemacht, weil mein Zimmer war jetzt gerade nicht so gesegnet mit der Abdeckung von diesen Access Points da, von dem Hotel. Also hab ich da frech auch draußen, als ich vor der Tür war, meinen Vater ange facetimed. Wir hatten mal eine Zeit zusammen in London, vor vielen, vielen Jahren. Und ich hab gesagt, so guck mal, so sieht es jetzt hier aus, so live mit Facetime.
Hältst du denn das für einen Preis, der auch wirklich, also man macht das auf dich, den Eindruck, dass sie damit auch Geld verdienen können?
Ich denke schon. Ich meine drei ist jetzt nicht gerade der längste Markt-Contender da. Es erzeugt so ein bisschen Druck auch bei den anderen, aber es gibt auch ähnliche Tarife bei O2, wir haben auch ein anderes Telefon, da haben wir extra aus Gründen sozusagen nochmal ein anderes SIM für genommen, nämlich eins von O2. Die bieten auch so einen ähnlichen Tarif an, weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob der auch so restriction-free ist, aber auch so mit unlimited data oder so. Dafür nerven sie dich mit SMS, unglaublich. Knallen dich mit Werbung voll und hier nimm doch noch unser Paket so und so und jeden Tag drei SMS und so, das war wirklich sehr eklig. Aber das etabliert sich so an dem Markt und wie gesagt, wenn du das einfach hochrechnest, habt ihr eben gesagt, was die Megabitze kosten auf Provider-Ebene. Was ich halt eben schön finde, ist, dass die drei Leute offensichtlich verstanden haben, dass sie dort ein stumpfer ESP sind, nur mit ohne Schnur und dass sie jetzt nicht anfangen, diese Mücken zu machen mit ja, und du musst aber hier telefonieren, über unten sind da und so. Also in diesen 15 Pfund sind auch noch x Minuten Domestic Telefonie drin oder keine Ahnung, 2000 SMS oder irgendwie so was, aber das ist auch noch mit drin, aber hab ich nicht benutzt. So großartig.
Ja, ich würde auch einen Tarif nehmen ohne SMS.
Die, nee, gibt's nicht, ist da mit drin, gibt's halt so, fertig. Die SIM von drei expired auch nicht, wenn du sie mindestens alle drei Monate mal im Netz sehen lässt, auch im Roaming. Das heißt, wenn du da einmal hinfährst, dir so ein Ding da kaufst, die kostet wohl einen Pfund oder so was selber, das heißt also, die 15 Pfund sind der Tarif, ich hab aber 16 plus Steuer bezahlt, irgendwie ein paar zerdrückte, weil die SIM selber noch mal einen Pfund kostet und 15 war halt der Aufladebetrag. Und wenn ich die jetzt hier mindestens alle drei Monate mal auch hier im deutschen Netz einbuche oder so, dann bleibt die ewig leben. Das SIM-Bastel-Projekt.
Willst du denn ewig leben?
Ja, willst du. Hab mir nämlich überlegt, ich hab ja so ein paar von diesen Karten aus aller Herren Länder und ich bin ja jetzt voll auf dem Trip mit den Raspberry-Pies und so. Ich hab mir jetzt bald gebastelt, hab mir nämlich einen schönen Siebenport-Switch gekauft, weil es gerade keinen längeren gab. Und so ein USB-Switch und so diese alten USB-Sticks, weißt du, diese UMTS-USB-Sticks, die gibt's jetzt inzwischen bei eBay und so für ein Zehner. Da pack ich jetzt meine ganzen ausländischen SIMs rein, steck die da rein und drück die dem Raspberry-Pie in den Hintern, hab da so ein kleines Programmchen drauf, was sich mit den Sticks unterhält und mit den SIM-Karten aktiv hält und guckt, ob irgendein Provider mir ne Message schickt, aller so, hallo, wenn du jetzt nicht mal Piep sagst, deaktivieren dir die Karte oder so. Und das Ding lass ich jetzt hier stehen. Das hebt mir sozusagen die SIMs auf. Dadurch sind sie eingebucht im Netz und selbst wenn nicht...
Also sie müssen jetzt auch nicht in dem Land eingebucht sein, sondern Hauptsache sind irgendwo Rom.
Ja, es gibt welche, die Rom auch nicht, aber die drei Dinge aus UK, die Rom auch in meiner Schwedischkarte auch. Und die Spanische auch und also die meisten von diesen Dingern Rom auch. Und dann hast du sozusagen so ne kleine Batterie von diesen Dingern da zu hängen und das hält dir das am Leben. Und wenn du das nächste Mal in das Land fährst, dann zupfst halt die SIM-Karte raus und gut ist. Wie gesagt, gerade für UK, dachte ich mir, würde dich ja vielleicht interessieren.
Wieso?
Keine Ahnung.
Falls du zurückziehen willst.
Falls du mal wieder bei im Bletchley Park mal reingucken willst oder so.
Ja, ab und zu mal, aber an sich ist das ja nicht so spannend.
Jetzt ihr.
Wie war das AT&T in Amiland, wollte uns irgendwie 70 Dollar für die SIM-Karte abnehmen. Ohne, dass da irgendein Tarif drauf ist.
Das ist ohnehin, in Amiland ist dieses Konzept der SIM erst vor wenigen Jahren rausgekommen. Das war lange, lange, lange Zeit so nach Einführung von GSM dort, weil sie dazu gewohnt waren, dass sie dieses Faktum, dass dein eigentlicher Vertrag an diesem Kärtchen da hinten drin hängt, den Usern nicht durchgereicht haben. Das war immer in der Werbung buy our phone. Und wenn du in einen Laden gegangen bist, hast du gesagt, ich hätte gerne mal ein Phone, aber ohne SIM haben die dich immer angeguckt, wie so ein Auto. Weil die haben halt Telefone in den Läden, da sind die SIMs schon drin. Und war zwar möglich, aber ist immer so ein spezielles Ding. Und jetzt erst in den letzten Jahren, man sieht jetzt schon in komischen Ami-Krimi-Folgen, wenn da ist immer sozusagen der Black Hat, wenn der flieht mit dem Taxi, reißt er erst mal die SIM-Karte raus aus seinem Telefon und tritt irgendwie drauf oder schmeißt er aus dem Fenster oder sonst irgendwas, also jetzt haben sie verstanden, dass es sowas gibt. Und es gibt übrigens auch, weil du gerade USA erwähnst, auch ein interessantes Thema, wir hatten ja auch Leute aus den USA da und es gab Leute, die zum Beispiel bei T-Mobile, bei der deutschen T-Mobile in den USA Kunde sind. Und die haben gesagt, ich kaufe mir keine britische SIM, weil ich kriege von T-Mobile kostenlos Data-Roaming. Was gibt es von der deutschen Telekom?
Ja, ja, habe ich neulich schon einen Bockpost drüber gesehen, dass das jetzt da irgendwie etwas so geht.
Okay, sie sind jetzt nicht der Marktführer in den USA und versuchen damit wahrscheinlich verzweifelt Kunden zu erringen, aber... Ne, so überhaupt nicht. Sollen mir doch keiner sagen, dass das nicht geht? Sie behaupten ja hier in Europa, ja und Roaming, kostenlose Roaming bringt uns alle um und wir werden alle sterben und so, ja. Aber offensichtlich...
Ich glaube, die Telekom verdient sogar Geld mit T-Mobile in den USA.
Ja, die Telekom verdient angeblich sogar Geld mit T-Mobile in den USA und trotzdem machen sie solche Deals.
Das ist erstaunlich, ne?
Ja, also von daher...
Ja, die Angestellten in dem T-Mobile-Laden waren aber trotzdem am rumheulen, dass es ihnen nicht so gut geht.
Ja, die Angestellten, das kann natürlich sein, ja.
So geht's bei allen Angestellten.
In diesen Läden.
So, jetzt müssen wir schnell noch mal ein anderes Thema aufwärmen, bevor Clemens hier überhaupt nicht mehr aufwärmt.
Ja, ein kleiner Aufheiterer zwischendurch. Wir haben ja heute Sendung 128 und so, ne? Da passt dieses kleine Edelsteinchen von Spiel ganz gut rein. Heute auf Facebook hab ich das gefunden. War toll. Und zwar dieses schöne Spiel, was jetzt auch im Chat vielleicht und in den Show-Notes, ist das schon im Chat? Nee, noch nicht. Hier ist es. Und zwar ist es...
Jetzt hört uns keiner mehr zu, oder was?
Ja, doch, noch. Noch ja. Sie müssen ja erstmal verstehen, wie es geht. Und zwar so ein kleines Puzzlespiel, wo es das Ziel ist, zwei Zahlen immer miteinander zusammen zu mergen und dann irgendwann auch einen Stein zu bekommen, der 2048 als Wert hält. Also man hat zum Beispiel zwei Steine mit jeweils einer 2, dann wird da 4 draus, 8 und so weiter und so fort und man kann halt erstmal so ganz random loslegen und dann hört es aber auch relativ schnell auf, weil man dann so einzelne Steininseln hat, die man nicht mehr mit anderen kombinieren kann. Also es wird am Anfang, denkt man so, ja das daddel ich jetzt einfach so weg, aber je weiter man kommt, desto strategischer muss man dann auch sozusagen seine Züge schon ein bisschen vorausdenken. Also es hat dann so Schachmomente, wo man so denkt, ah jetzt hab ich da den 32er und da unten ist ein 32er, die muss ich jetzt irgendwie so hoch zusammenschieben, dass ich die...
Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was man hier schiebt.
Ich verstehe auch, die Steuerung ist mir total unklar.
Was steuer ich denn überhaupt?
Du steuerst mit den Cursor-Tasten, auf welche Seite die Steine fallen.
Alle?
Alle.
Wie fallen?
Drück mal runter jetzt.
Drück mal runter. Genau, dann fallen die zwei Zweien runter.
Achso, an die Wand schick ich sie sozusagen.
An die Wand, genau.
Und wann kommt neuer?
Und was passiert dann?
Bei jedem zu kommt ein neuer Stein aufs Spielbrett.
Wenn ich jetzt hier rechts klicke, kommt kein neuer.
Naja, weil es hat sich nix bewegt dann bei dir. Du musst jetzt mal hoch oder...
Mach mal nach links jetzt.
When two tiles with the same number touch, they merge into one. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt nach rechts gehe, müsste ich zwei Vieren haben.
Genau.
Es gibt dann auch ein Ende, wenn du dich nicht mehr zusammenschieben lässt, hast du glatt verloren.
Genau. So, das heißt du willst immer Freifelder frei haben, damit du noch Bewegungsspielraum hast.
Game over, fuck.
Und das heißt, zum Beispiel total super ist es, wenn du gleich drei Steine, also sechs Steine zusammen mergeln kannst, weil du dann plötzlich wieder so richtig viel Platz hast. Genau, aber es sind meistens zwei oder vier. So, und jetzt angenommen, du hast einen Stein, der schon bei 512 ist, weil du so richtig geil zusammengemerged hast, dann hast du jetzt plötzlich diesen 512er-Block da drin, den du ganz lange nicht mit dem Rest mergeln kannst, weil du jetzt erstmal wieder die anderen kleinen Steinchen ringsrum auch auf 512 bringen musst. Also es wird sozusagen immer, immer schwieriger. Und wenn du es jetzt sozusagen so ein paar Mal rumgedaddelt hast, dann irgendwann packt dich so der Ehrgeiz, okay, jetzt will ich mal das Spielfeld so lange wie möglich schön frei haben und jetzt so richtig überlegen, okay, welche Steine schiebe ich denn wie am besten zusammen, genau und...
Hast du es denn schon geschafft bis 2048?
Nee, ich hab's geschafft. Ich hatte den einen 512er und einen 256er und bevor ich die zum 1024er machen konnte, war schon vorbei. Und oben zählt eine Score mit. Meine Highscore ist gerade 5036, aber ich weiß, die ganzen Hörer werden wir wahrscheinlich in den Kommentaren posten hier, 10.000, 20.000 irgendwie, da wird es bestimmt genug Freaks geben. Also ich hab auch das so angeguckt, ach ja, ist ja ganz nett und dann irgendwie, als ich das nächste Mal auf die Uhr geguckt hab, musste ich auch schon los zum Podcasten. Also man kann sich da so, wenn man mal gerade nebenbei einfach mal nur so eine kleine Runde spielen will und dazu noch sozusagen lernen will, wie das so mit den Bits und Bytes, wie sind nochmal die Schlüssellängen und die Auflösungen und die... Da kann man sich ganz schnell einprägen. Also ich finde, das ist halt, das ist auf GitHub, es hat schon jemand geklonet und eine Multiplayer-Version davon gemacht. Also da kann ich ja auch gerade nochmal hier raussuchen. Wo war denn das? Und wer hat mir die geschickt? Ja, oder wenn ihr danach sucht, 2048 Multiplayer findet ihr bestimmt. Aber ja, fand ich auf jeden Fall eine echt coole Puzzle-Idee. Und da ist jetzt eben ohne Werbung, ohne Bezahlen, ohne alles einfach nur so ein kleines Puzzle-Spiel mit so einem ganz...
Und das Java-Skriptrader, das läuft doch dann schön auf dem iPhone oder?
Das läuft doch auf dem Phone, ja. Ich hab das Leute schon mit Touch spielen sehen.
Also gewonnen hab ich, wenn ich einen einzigen Teil kriege, der auf 2048 gekommen ist. Jetzt bin ich da mit 64 und den muss ich sozusagen weiter hochleveln.
Genau.
Oh je, das ist ja echt ein Zeitfresser, verdammte Scheiße.
Nur den Spaß macht das irgendwie nicht. Man schiebt da so lustlos Zeug hin und her.
Ja, weil du noch nicht jetzt hier...
Angefressen bist.
Dazu gekommen bist, mal nachzudenken, wie du da die Moves am besten machst, wahrscheinlich.
Alter, deine Moves, man, check mal deine Moves.
Get your Moves on. Ich finde es ein cooles Puzzlespiel.
Also bisher läuft es ganz gut, also...
Ja, und 228, ja man, nicht schlecht, ja. Wie gesagt, meine Highscore ist 5000, Dennis, also...
Ganz lustig, ich schiebe gerade randommäßig mit meinen Fingern auf dem Touch-Ding hinterher, ich bin schon bei 32.
Das war jetzt das mit den Produzenten, mit den Podcasts.
Man kommt mit random behavior, kommt man so bis 2000 Punkte auch ohne weiteres manchmal, aber wie gesagt, wenn man jetzt so schon weiter kommen will, dann muss man ein bisschen mehr nachdenken.
Nachdenken?
Also so halt so, weißt du, so ein bisschen schachmäßig, so du musst dann halt so ein bisschen in Züge schon vorausgucken. Ja, wie gesagt, das ist jetzt nix Großartiges, aber auf jeden Fall sehr nett gemacht und Was war dein Rekord? Meine Highscore ist 5000, noch irgendwas, 5036.
Aber ich denke, es zählt immer nur was...
Ja, rechts oben zählt da doch deine Score für jeden Move sozusagen, zählt da deine Kombination mit, damit du sozusagen, weil du die 2048, die ist halt verdammt schwer zu erreichen, wenn es überhaupt schon jemand geschafft hat, ja, und damit du trotzdem so ein bisschen dich mit deinen Freunden betteln kannst, dann gibt es halt oben noch so einen Scorezähler.
Also ich habe das 256er Stück jetzt immerhin schon mal gehabt.
Ja, vor dem Podcast habe ich einen 512er hingekriegt, unter Roddy's Supervision.
Ich habe schon 128, ich mach mich.
Dennis hat ja schon, Dennis hat schon 256.
Das wird aber exponentiell schwerer.
Ich habe vorhin gesagt, ich falle nicht drauf rein.
Dennis, jetzt bist du doch cool. Dennis, Tim. Tim hat vorhin gesagt, er spiele und so, damit kann er nichts anfangen und ich meinte so, also wenn du das Spiel nicht so wenigstens so ein bisschen cool findest, dann, also das kann man schon akzeptieren, aber schon merkwürdig.
Ich hab ja gesagt, ich mag nur so ganz bestimmte Spiele.
Das ist halt ein schönes Klospiel und so auch, ne? Klospiel?
Wie lange würdest du noch im Klo sitzen? Alter!
Alter!
Andere wollen auch mal!
Ja, also...
Wollen wir jetzt Schluss machen, wenn der Podcast ist?
Ey, komm, jetzt hast du nur zwei Felder frei, mal sehen.
Ey, jetzt ziehen aber auch Zeiten auf, ey. Also, ich meine, Tim findet iOS 7 plötzlich gut. Nein, war doch so, dachte ich.
Benutzt Reaper zum Aufzeichnen?
Mit 7.1 sagtest du, es ist alles super.
Auf dem iPhone 4?
Wann hab ich das gesagt?
Hat er das gesagt? Also, die Einschränkung?
Auf dem iPhone 4, ja.
Auf dem iPhone 4?
Ja, auf dem iPhone 4 ist es jetzt besser, wenn man sein iPhone 4, mit dem iOS 7 Gott schon geopfert hat, dann kriegt man etwas Schmerz erlassen.
Der erste Hörer ist schon bei 6.000 Punkten.
Also bei meinem iPhone, ich bin noch auf iOS 6. Ich gib's zu. Ich bin irgendwie vulnerable und das ist alles, das fühlt sich alles irgendwie falsch an. Aber ich merke einfach immer wieder welche, ich benutze dieses Telefon wirklich gerne. Ich mag das. Und es gibt so paar Features, die finde ich besonders toll. Die benutze ich laufend, die ganze Zeit. iOS 7 nimmt mir das. Ich weiß, ich mache es update und es ist weg. Und es wird wahrscheinlich nie, nie wiederkommen, weil er mich heute beschlossen hat.
In iOS 10.7 bringen sie den Feature, was in iOS 6 schon mal drin war. Weißt du, wie es ist? Verstehst du nicht die Parallele?
Ich merke es schon.
Halte nur noch 20 Jahre durch. Nach links, nach links, yes.
Was hast du getan?
Das ist schon 4200 Punkte. Ich habe 512 am Start hier.
Echt? Wie gesagt, der erste Hörer ist schon über 6000 Punkte.
Dann können wir den Podcast jetzt eigentlich auch einpacken.
Wir gehen jetzt nur noch Moves. Das fehlt echt noch die Sounds. Multi Merch.
Das ist so, ich kann mich aus einer Aussicht. Siehst du mal, ich kann mich aus einer aussichtslosen Situation befreien. Interessiert euch gar nicht, also als meine Lieblingsfeatures.
Ja, doch das Feature würde ich jetzt schon gerne wissen.
Also ich weiß, manche Leute nehmen das nicht so zur Kenntnis, aber ich benutze das am dauernd. Safari-Rider.
Ja, das trägt so die Seite noch nicht mehr.
Ja, ich meine, wenn ich auf dem iPhone so ein Spiegelartikel lesen will, dann gucke ich mir das noch nicht in diesem Desktop oder gar in diesem Mobile-View an, sondern dann rufe ich halt die normale Webseite auf, wo natürlich alles viel zu klein ist. Und weil Spiegel online auch seine Webseiten immer so furchtbar breit machen muss jetzt, kriegst du da einfach keine ordentlichen Fondzeiten hin.
Es gibt keinen Reader mehr in Safari? Aber?
Naja, der Reader in dem neuen Safari, kannst du ja mal ausprobieren, der macht ja dann das so alles ein bisschen größer und dann hast du so ein bisschen so hellwittiger Kram. Manchmal hast du auch noch die Werbung noch mit drin, was vorher komplett entfernt war. Aber du kannst halt die...
Das könnte aber auch an den Webseiten liegen, die jetzt inzwischen mitgekriegt haben, dass es da draußen Reader gibt, die ihnen ihre Einnahmequelle töten und dass sie die jetzt inzwischen so gestalten, dass es eben nicht mehr so leicht sich reedert.
Die Reader töten ja nicht, der Safari Reader tötet überhaupt gar keine Einnahme, weil ihre Page-Load haben sie zu dem Zeitpunkt ja schon bekommen.
Ja, aber sie werden nicht mehr angezeigt.
Doch, du lädst ja die Seite, da werden sie angezeigt. Und dann sagst du, das hätte ich jetzt ganz gerne mal in Lesbar, so und damit du es halt auch wirklich mal inhaltlich zur Kenntnis nehmen kannst.
Bei der Tuts geht es noch.
Und im iOS 6 Reader hast du halt einfach eine Tasse, mit der du die Fontgröße einstellen kannst. Und die Defaults bei iOS 7, also erstmal ist es ein Sorcery-Font, also sie machen da irgendwie so einen Helvetica-Bolt-Font, der viel zu klein ist. Das ist immer noch alles viel zu klein. Also es verbessert die Situation etwas, aber gut lesen kann ich es damit immer noch nicht.
Aber wir haben ja eh schon mal festgestellt, dass du eigentlich eine Brille bräuchtest, ne? Ich?
Warum?
Hatten wir das nicht schon mal in der Sendung? Ich erinnere mich, dass wir schon mal dieses Thema hatten.
Keine Ahnung, was du da schon für Erkenntnisse hattest. Ich meine, mein Augenlicht, das ist sowieso mein bester Sinn. Also ich kann nicht so gut hören, aber ich kann gut sehen.
Wann warst du das letzte Mal beim Sehtest?
Gut hören kannst du schlecht, aber schlecht hören kannst du gut.
Ich war vor gar nicht so langer Zeit beim Sehtest und ich bestehe alles. Und ich kann auch immer noch irgendwie Straßenschilder auf 100 Metern erkennen. Also ich habe kein Problem mit dem Sehen. Aber ich habe ein Problem mit dem Safari-Rider. Das sind halt so Sachen, an die habe ich mich jetzt so gewohnt. Und ich weiß einfach, es gefällt mir halt bei iOS nicht. Es ist halt einfach echt nicht schick. Da frage ich mich halt immer wieder, was habe ich denn eigentlich davon? So, jetzt ist ja dieses 7.1 rausgekommen.
Ja, es ist schneller.
Man muss ja mal sagen, auf welchem Telefon ist es für dich schneller?
Auch auf dem 5er hier, ja.
Also auf dem 5er ist es schneller.
Also auf dem 5S habe ich nichts gemerkt.
Ja, aber auf dem 5er sind bestimmte Sachen snappier. Oder sie haben die Animationen einfach schneller abgespielt, wie auch immer. Ja, das ist auch so.
Damit habe ich eigentlich auch gerechnet, dass sie das alles wieder so ein bisschen zurücknehmen. Und es scheint ja auch alles ein wenig zurückgenommen zu haben. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass ich kein iOS 7 hätte. Ich habe ja hier noch mein iPhone 4. Und da ist es drauf.
Gibt es noch Schoki?
Und das ist, es gab schon vorher keine.
Hallo, was ist eigentlich hier mit Törergeschenken und Schokolade und so?
Du hast heute 10 Euro geschenkt bekommen in bar.
Ja, die habe ich gleich weitergegeben in den Pizzatopf hier. Da liegen sie.
Wieso denn in den Pizzatopf?
Ich habe die jetzt hier gespendet, weil ich keinen Bock habe, 10 Euro bei der Steuer zu deklarieren.
Die Pizza kriegen wir eh, nach dem Timmerman soll er Schoki kaufen.
Mir ist jetzt egal, wo sie herkommt, ob geschenkt oder gekauft, jetzt her mit den Drogen.
Ich soll jetzt auch noch Schoki kaufen.
Jetzt bedanken wir uns jetzt erstmal artig bei dem edlen Spender, der ja etwas ideenlos ist, was die Geschenkeauswahl anbelangt, aber eigentlich genau meinen Geschmack getroffen hat.
Vom Design her, ja, mit dem Zettel.
Nur Wahres ist Wahres, ne? Dann ist gleich unter das Kopfkissen damit.
So sieht's aus, auf jeden Fall nicht zu Mount Bank.
Das gleiche mit Bitcoin umwandeln.
Aber Jungs, unsere Bitcoin-Adressen stehen da auf der Seite, ihr müsst gar keine Post schicken und so.
Ich hab keine Adresse.
Posts ja auch, Porto und alles, ist unsicher. Hätte auch weg sein können.
Und jetzt in den Zeiten sind viele Leute wieder skeptisch geworden in Deutschland.
Von welchem Thema sind wir gerade angekommen?
2048.
Du warst bei 7.1 und den Verschnellerten Transitions und all sowas. Und dass man jetzt endlich den Parallax-Effekt abschalten kann, aber irgendeinen haben sie noch übrig gelassen.
Ja, und sind die Icons jetzt bei euch eigentlich auch insgesamt alle fetter, oder ist das nur, weil ich hier irgendeinen Accessibility-Kram angeschaltet habe?
Ja, da bin ich mir auch nicht so. Das sieht irgendwie ein bisschen deutlicher aus, so kontrastreicher.
Es ist, glaube ich, etwas weniger dünn geworden. Kann das sein, oder ist es nur im Accessibility-Modus? Hast du den eingeschaltet? Ich muss mal kurz schauen.
Aha, mit deinem Augenlicht ist noch alles okay, aber du schaltest den Accessibility-Modus ein.
Mit deinem Hintergrund, da ist irgendwie nichts.
Vorher war mir das alles zu dünn. Fetter Text habe ich angeschaltet.
Ja.
Also der Parallax-Effekt ist weg, aber die Eichens bewegen sich immer noch so ein bisschen, wenn man so dreht. Das ist schon... Die machen da komischen Vodoo-Kram, ey. Deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich immer so schwindlig in letzter Zeit.
Du meinst, der Parallax-Effekt ist sowieso raus?
Nee, du kannst den jetzt in Wallpaper, wenn du dein Wallpaper aussuchst, dann kannst du da den Parallax-Effekt...... kompliziert an- und ausschalten, und sogar getrennt für den Home-Screen und für den Log-Screen.
Tja, so bleibt irgendwie alles...... alles auf der Strecke hier langsam.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt so mache und das gar nicht bewege, dann sieht es trotzdem anders aus. Wenn sich meine Optik zum Telefon gar nicht ändert, aber das Telefon trotzdem, dann wandern hier die Eigens hoch und runter. Also die Eigens, die bewegen sich noch, wenn man sein iPhone hier so hin und her schwenkt. Ich finde das ja total bescheuert.
So, jetzt habe ich mal wieder dünne Schrift eingeschaltet. Es scheint mir alles etwas etwas fetter geworden zu sein.
Möchtest du uns an dieser Stelle nochmal erwähnen, dass die Diskussion über Schokolade nicht zufriedenstellend abgeschlossen wurde?
Es gibt halt keine.
Wie, du hast ja nichts zu liegen? Können wir nicht was von Holgi plündern oder so? Kann auch nicht sein, denn hier ist alles voll mit irgendwelchen Kisten.
Wir können hier gar nicht richtig durchs Studio laufen vor lauter Geschenken.
Ja Leute, sorry, da reicht die Platter Cola jetzt eigentlich nicht dafür, dass ich euch auch noch irgendwie komplett durchgekommen habe.
Nein, aber es gibt doch jede Menge, jede Menge höherer Geschenke. Notfalls, nimm mal was von Holgi, der kriegt auch mal unsere.
Genau, oder du gibst es deinen Kids, weil, weil, ähm...
Weil Bodennebel.
Schau, wie im Tels.
No shit.
Ich hab hier so ein neues Game am Start, das heißt Film-Alphabet. Und das ging immer nicht. Also ich hab hier das, äh, wie heißt das, wenn man hier in-app purchases, wenn man sich das vollkauft, keine Ahnung. Ich hab jedenfalls da den Rest bezahlt, aber wenn man den Rest kriegt, weißt schon, und das ging nicht. Es hat immer gecrashed und hat mein App-Store irgendwie runtergezogen und jetzt mit 7.1 geht's plötzlich, das Game. Also es kam kein Update, also es lag an 7.1. Und jetzt kann ich endlich mein Game spielen hier.
Hashtag, was fehlt? So ein Laden, die dir ähnlich wie eine Pizza auch einfach mal ein paar Tafeln Schokolade vorbeibringt. Ich finde nämlich, dass wir das Thema immer noch nicht zufriedenstellend abgeschlossen haben, Herr Prittler. Jetzt lasst du einem hier mal was anderes.
Diese Anspruchshaltung, ne?
Lass uns lieber noch mal über 7.1 reden. Also ich habe es jetzt rausgefunden, wenn man dieses fette Text anschaltet, dann kriegt man jetzt auch fette Icons. Das heißt, es ist alles nicht mehr so dünn. Wobei ich ja befürchte, dass man sich wirklich dran gewöhnen kann mit der Zeit. Was haben sie denn da mit der Tastatur gemacht? Da ist doch irgendwie auch was komisches.
Die Shift-Taste ist strange.
Das kann man gleich mal so ganz klar sagen.
Was hat sich denn da eigentlich verändert? Also vorher war die, hatte die irgendwie eine andere…
Ist das jetzt die Shift-Lock-Taste, oder was, wenn ich die richtig sehe, oder wie?
Nee, die Art, wie sie shiftet, ist komisch. Also wenn die gedrückt ist, sieht sie aus, als wäre sie nicht gedrückt. Genau.
Und sie sieht scheiße aus. Irgendwie ist sie so ein bisschen ihr Geschmacksprofil abhanden gekommen.
Was ist denn eigentlich hier mit Sir? Von dem haben wir noch lange nichts mehr gehört. Wie Steve? Nein, Sir...
Was willst du von dem sehen?
Keine Ahnung. Der hat doch mal wie eine dicke Hose gemacht. Vor allem, die einen anderen Vogel rausgeschmissen haben. Und jetzt hört man von dem seit Monaten nichts mehr.
Dicke Hose?
Ja, aber ich kann dir sagen, was der gerade macht. Du darfst aber nicht weiter sagen. Ne, der muss gerade das, was sie mit iOS 7 gemacht haben, muss der gerade mit OS X machen.
Oh fuck, das wird schlimm.
Es könnte sein, dass Mavericks das letzte OS ist, das man noch benutzen kann. Ja, wenn die da jetzt auch, ich meine, was kommt da jetzt? Auch alle Buttons weg und überall nur noch diese komischen HTML-Dinger. Jetzt gibt es doch hier auch diese Accessibility, dass du da so Tastin-Formen einschalten kannst. Wo dann diese etwas obskure, grau hinterlegte Simulation der alten Buttons wieder kommt. Kannst machen. Du hast halt nicht diesen Pfeil mit dem Text, sondern du hast halt den Text auf einem grauen Button, der Pfeilform hat. So wie die Buttons halt vorher auch aussahen.
Und das verstecken sie jetzt bei den Behindertenfunktionen, nach dem Motto, wer das braucht, ist behindert, oder wie?
Bedienungshilfe heißt das.
Aber die Message ist schon nicht ganz verkehrt.
Leute, reißt euch zusammen. Auf jeden Fall...
Na, ich hab das da nicht eingebaut.
Es ist eine Bedienungshilfe.
Es ist eine Bedienungshilfe. Ich finde nur nicht, dass es jetzt besonders gut aussieht.
Nee, die Buttons, die sehen ganz schlimm aus. Also es sind wieder Buttons, man erkennt sie wieder als Buttons.
Jaja, man ist hier gespalten. Eigentlich wollte man die Buttons aber so nicht.
Also es ist doch eher eine Bedienungshilfe für alte Leute.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, es wirkt so ein bisschen so, als hätten sie die eingebaut, weil alle geschrien haben, und dann haben sie sie extra hässlich eingebaut. Das sind ja alle, die geschrien haben von den Leuten, die nicht geschrien haben, eins drüber gezündet bekommen. So nach der Art, äh Buttons, sieht doch voll scheiße aus. Aber ich mag mich täuschen.
Hast du dir immer diesen Link gepostet, den ich da gepostet hab, mit dem Vergleich, dieses Polar-Dings? Genau, weil da kann man nämlich nochmal, weil es ist schon doch eine ganze Menge passiert bei 7.1 und da kann man mal so, genau das Ding, hat man mal so einen Überblick. Das ist eigentlich ganz schick, weil da war eine Menge drin, was ich auch noch nicht kannte.
Ja, vor allem haben sie halt diese riesen, breiten, mega fetten Tastenflächen, die haben sie halt irgendwie rausgenommen gegen kleine runde, glubbe Buttonzettel.
Ja, und ich finde sie eigentlich genau...
Beim Telefon.
Die Mitte nehmen sollen, also nicht, sie hätten ihn nicht rund machen sollen, sie hätten ihn aber auch nicht so eckig bis an den Rand wie vorher machen sollen, sondern ein bisschen kleiner als der Bildschirm, so zwei Dritte oder die Hälfte vielleicht, und dann aber trotzdem abgerundet. Also jetzt nur rund ist mir auch ein bisschen zu klein.
Jetzt sieht es wieder aus wie eine Taste.
Sieht ja auch aus wie der Homebutton, ja. Schrecklich.
Ich finde das jetzt nicht so schlimm. Das sieht auf jeden Fall besser aus als vorher.
Was mich immer irritiert hat, die seit letztes Jahr, Oktober, war noch immer hier, seitdem ich 7.0 habe, ist immer, wenn mich Leute anrufen, und ich bin in Hektik und will rangehen, ich klicke mal drauf und es passiert immer nichts. Und ich denke, habe ich nicht getroffen und klicke mal mehr drauf, bis ich merke, ach ja, du musst ja swipen. Das ging mir so auf den Sack.
Ja, aber man musste da vorher schon swipen.
Wo musste man swipen?
Soll man ins Telefon zugehen? Ja, ich habe das immer optisch nicht gepeilt. Das ist jetzt deutlicher. Das sagt mir jetzt mehr, was es haben will von mir. Vorher war das in diesem Grün mit dem weißen Text drauf, glaube ich, oder was auch immer das war. Das war irgendwie nicht so gut zu erkennen. Ich habe das immer... Da, guck! Also kannst du sehen, jetzt was da steht? Anser. Kannst du das lesen? Das kann noch kein Schwein erkennen.
Das ist ja jetzt auf dem Beamer, nicht auf meinem Telefon.
Auf dem Telefon siehst du das auch nicht besser.
Außer in diesen Gewische auf dem Telefon, die Leute glauben, das ist ein Android-Telefon. Das geht gar nicht.
Ja, aber dieses ganze Hellgrau ist jetzt so ein bisschen... Es ist alles etwas prägnanter. Es ist alles nicht mehr so hell. Es ist alles nicht mehr so dünn. Es bricht alles nicht mehr so weg. Und die Farben sind auch nicht mehr so gräl. Die haben auch dieses furchtbare, hässliche Grün von diesen Icons. Das hat mich schon am meisten gestört. Das ist jetzt auch irgendwie halbwegs gebändigt. Also, gib dir noch ein paar Jahre, dann wird das wieder.
Naja, dann kommt das nächste iOS 7. Dann bist du wieder im Schimpfen.
Merke dir, jede gute alte Zeit war mal eine schlechte neue Zeit.
Das trifft auf dich besonders zu, oder?
Naja, aber es gab schon eine Zeit, da sind wir jedem Update eifrig fiebernd entgegen gerannt. Betas installiert, bis der Arzt kommt und Spaß dabei gehabt.
Betas installiere ich ja schon leider nicht mehr.
Jetzt ist es eher so das Gefühl, dass es jedes Mal schlimmer wird.
Ne, ich finde es toll.
Clemens, hast du ein Auto, wo man dieses Card-Display zum Aufkappen einsbringen kann?
Ich hab ein Deutschland-Auto, das braucht noch eine Weile. Ein Deutschland-Auto aus Deutschland für deutsche Konsumenten, das braucht. Bei meinem Autohersteller, wenn ich dir jetzt anrufe, was haben sie so an Handy-Halterungen, bieten sie mir Nokia 6230 oder so was an?
Ernsthaft?
Ja, keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Sie haben inzwischen schon iPhones entdeckt, aber die Integration da ist fürchterlich ein bisschen davon. Ich weigere mich ja immer, deren unglaublich sauteure Navi-Zeug zu kaufen. Und im Moment sind sie so pissed, dass sie dir das Auto ziemlich verkrüppeln, was zu dieser ganzen Elektronik da angeht. Was soll ich mir ein Navi bei BMW kostet? Keine 1.500 Euro. Ich brauch das nicht. Ich hab das beste Navi, was es gibt in 20 verschiedenen Softwareversionen auf meinem iPhone. Das will ich benutzen und nicht den Schmuddel von denen. Aber wenn du das nicht hast, dann hast du diese Display auch nicht. Und ohne diese Display hast du auch irgendwie einen anderen Kack nicht. Und dann geht das alles nicht in dem Auto. Und ich sehe das jetzt auch noch nicht. Die sind da mal sehr, sehr ruhig. Das dauert auch immer ewig.
Wenn die Navis in den Autos toll wären, dann würde es dem Telefon gar nicht geben.
Es gibt zum Beispiel Siri schon seit Ewigkeiten. Und jetzt habe ich die mal gefragt. Ich habe ja so eine Bluetooth-Anbindung da, wenigstens mit dem Knopf auf dem Lenkrad zum Annehmen. Und habe gesagt, können wir das mal so bauen, dass wenn ich da jetzt mal länger drauf drücke, dass Siri mit mir spricht?
Nö.
Gibt es auch nicht. Gibt es auch keine Software-Updates und nix. Kein gar nichts. Ja, das ist bei Daimler nicht wesentlich anders.
Ja gut, aber genau das ist doch das, was jetzt dieses Carplay bringen soll.
Ja, aber gibt es nicht. Die Rücken rüsten auch nix nach oder sowas.
Ja, aber BMW gehört doch zu den Leuten, die jetzt auch...
Ja, damit sie da irgendwo für irgendein extra-la-la-Modell, Only North America, bla, irgendwie...
Nur für neue Modelle natürlich.
Ja, aber auch dann erstmal wieder nur, keine Ahnung, North America wegen... Was ist ich für einen Grund? Also, das ist ein Abgrund.
Ja, das ist ein Abgrund. Das ist mir schon klar, aber trotzdem versuchen sie ja zumindest jetzt so wie bei Apple TV. Ich meine, Fernseher sind genauso ein Abgrund.
Ja, wenn Apple mal ein Auto bauen würde, dann könnte man darüber reden, ja, aber sonst...
Ja, aber das werden sie halt nicht, genauso wie sie kein Fernseher bauen.
Du, die haben ihr iTunes in irgendeinen Motorola eingebaut und das war scheiße. Und dann haben sie später ein Telefon gebaut. Jetzt bauen sie ihr Navi-Zollchen-Autos rein. Es ist scheiße.
Und dann?
Muss ich diesen Satz beenden?
Nee, musst du nicht.
Ja, okay, Apple wird keine Autos bauen. Aber...
Vielleicht werden sie...
Zutrauen würde ich es ihnen aber.
Vielleicht werden sie irgendwann Autos ausrüsten.
So ein Elektroauto oder so.
Na ja, ich meine, da gibt es so ein paar Platzirschen, wenn du guckst, was so in den Autos eingebaut ist. Früher war das ja so, zum Beispiel Jugend in Mayenblüte, da gab es ja da so ein genormtes Loch. Dann ist man in einen Laden gegangen, da hat sich das geilste Autoradio-Kopf, das da rein geschoben, dieses Standardloch hinten in den Standardstecker drauf gesteckt und dann hat das Auto gewummert. So.
Aber...
Heute ist es ja so, dass die alle mit irgendwelchen Radios von zu Hause kommen. Und wenn du dann guckst, so ein Daimler-Radio ist halt eben auch ein Bäcker-Radio. Mit Technik von Anno Tuff. Und klingt vielleicht noch ganz okay, aber passt dann auch speziell da rein. Weil sie auch immer noch Schiss vor Autoradio-Diemen haben. Ja, in 2014. Ja, aber... Und das heißt, du hast dann da welche Hersteller, Standardhersteller drin, die zu, keine Ahnung, wie viel... 90% oder sonst irgendwas auch wirklich in den Autos alle drinstecken. Und da könnte durchaus bei den wenigen Platzhirschen, die es da gibt, wie Blaupunkt oder Bäcker oder sowas, da könnte zum Beispiel wenn man in Apple hinkommt sagen, ihr habt da mal eine Auto TV oder so. Also theoretisch wäre das möglich, weil das halt ein sehr zentralistischer Markt ist, bis auf so ein paar Leute, die immer noch irgendwie sich so ein Standards-Lotter ergattern.
Naja, aber letzten Endes ist der Markt natürlich auch Kunden getrieben. Und wenn jetzt ein Volvo hergeht und sagt, wir bauen das ein und plötzlich gehen deren Verkäufe hoch und ein BMW merkt, der BMW-Händler will mir das neue Modell verkaufen, aber ich kaufe lieber ein Volvo, dann geht es, glaube ich, relativ schnell.
Da geht nichts schnell in diese Autoindustrie? Nichts.
Naja, relativ schnell für die Autoindustrie in nur vier Jahren.
Was ich ja nochmal ganz gerne ergründen würde, ist, was ist jetzt CarPlay eigentlich genau? Also auf der einen Seite ist es eine Ergänzung innerhalb von iOS, dass es eben mit etwas, was CarPlay, also was das sozusagen darstellt, kommuniziert.
Also so wie ich das sehe, ist es eine Art AirPlay-Display, das Touch haben kann oder aber noch weitere Bedienelemente wie ein Jogwheel oder ein Kasa-Tast.
Wobei Apple aber auch quasi die Software für dieses Touch-Gerät selber liefert.
Was dringend notwendig ist.
Dringend.
Weil diese Oberflächen in den Autoherstellern sind unglaublich abgründig.
Wahrscheinlich. Und gleichzeitig gibt es aber dann noch eine kleine schmale API, wo du als Software sagen kannst, ich hab hier Audio, das kannst du spielen. Also so nach der Art, ich hab hier, was weiß ich, irgendwelche Songs oder so. Also so ein Spotify oder so, keine Ahnung.
Das ist aber auch die einzige Partie-Integration, die es da gibt.
Soweit es bis jetzt bekannt ist, ja. Also es gibt ja diesen Hack für den Xcode, wo man auf dem Root-Verzeichnis vom Mac irgendwie ein Directory anlegt, was Apple Intern oder so heißt. Ich hab das doch da irgendwo aufgeschrieben. Apple Internal. Man legt dieses Verzeichnis an, Apple Internal, und wenn man dann das nächste Mal den iPhone-Simulator startet, dann hat man im Debug-Menü, im Hardware-Menü, wo man externe Displays hat, kann man plötzlich ein CarPlay-Display aufmachen. Das tut zwar nichts, also nichts wirklich, ich kann das hier mal zeigen, das tut wirklich gar nichts. Ja, ja, das User-Interface ist noch ein bisschen preliminary.
Es gibt das User-Interface.
Aber man kann es benutzen.
Oh mein Gott.
Nein, wirklich.
Mein BMW ist von 2011. Als ich damals mein iPhone an den USB-Port angesteckt habe, den dieses Auto mitbringt, hat sich mein Telefon in ein Flash-Memory verwandelt. Dann sagte das so, jo, ich werde jetzt hier vom Auto kontrolliert, und dann hast du auf diesem Autoradio mit einer Vorwärts- und einer Zurücktaste meine 4000 Quietsch-Itunes-Songs durchgeblättert. Dann hab ich den wieder abgesteckt und ewig nicht angefasst. Und erst neulich, als ich diese Brodethalterung hatte, hab ich es mal wieder angesteckt mit iOS 7, und seitdem ist das benutzbar. Seitdem kann man anders kontrolliert das Auto nicht mehr das Telefon, sondern das Auto ist sozusagen ein USB-Lautsprecher für das Telefon, so wie man es eigentlich haben will. Aber so viel zum Thema Usability oder sowas.
Ja, du hast entweder ein Touch-Display oder eben halt auch nicht, und dann hast du halt, wie gesagt, dieses Jogwheel oder so Cursor-Tasten usw. So wie ich das sehe, kannst du halt mit diesem ganzen Auswahlzeug von dem CarPlay entweder iTunes oder die Apple-Apps steuern oder halt irgendeine andere App, die irgendwie Songs oder Media, also das ist so ein Media-Player-Ding, wo du dann so Media, MP-Playable-Content-Manager heißt das Ding und dann kannst du halt so, wie heißt das Ding, MP-Content-Items kannst du dann zum Besten geben, die irgendwie halt Audio enthalten und ein Bild und ein Title und Artist und so ein Zeug. Also das ist, ja keine Ahnung, ob die Hersteller dann wirklich das Display mit der Elektronik von Apple da irgendwie verbauen müssen oder ob es da irgendwie eine Schnittstelle gibt, die die Hersteller dann ansprechen können oder so. Also das ist irgendwie ungeklärt.
Was sich ja auch noch geändert hat in iOS 7.1 ist das Behavior mit diesen Eye-Beacons.
Hast du dich schon mal irgendwie live gesehen?
Ja, also auf der CeBIT waren welche im Einsatz.
Ja, ich habe mal so Developer-Kit-Teile gesehen, wo du halt, naja, hast du so eine simple App, da steht dann drauf, ungefähr so und so weit von A entfernt und ungefähr so und so weit von B entfernt. Und das war's dann.
Das ist ja schon mal eine ganz gute Sache. Ich meine, letztlich muss man halt jetzt mit guten Ideen hochkommen für Eye-Beacons. Aber erstmal, was ist das überhaupt? Das sind halt so Bluetooth, FIA, LE-basierte Mini, Mini, Mini, Mini, Super-Mini-Devices, die nicht sehr viel mehr tun, als eine ID auszusenden. Da gibt es irgendwie so einen Standard dafür. Und in diesem Standard waren irgendwie noch, da ist so enthalten, also du hast halt eine, ganz klar, Bluetooth-Device, du hast halt eine MAC-Adresse. Dann hat dieses Gerät eine YUI-ID, die irgendwie so zehn, zwölf Zeichen lang ist oder so.
Na ja, eine normale YUI-ID, oder?
Na, was ist eine normale YUI-ID?
Die, die du mit Gen-YUI-ID bekommst. Das ist irgendwie ein Standard. Gibt es einen Standard für?
Gut, ich erinnere mich jetzt bloß nicht an die Länge. Keine Ahnung. Du kannst ja mal nachschauen.
Na, so 20, 30 Hexzeichen oder so, oder was das ist?
Na, sind irgendwelche Bits, die in drei Gruppen oder vier Gruppen irgendwie zusammengekugelt werden.
Genau, aber ich kann es jetzt gerade nicht quantifizieren. Und offensichtlich ist es so, dass Apple jetzt für diesen Brand-Name iBeacon, also wenn du ein Produkt quasi iBeacon kompatibel nennen möchtest, dann musst du halt nochmal zusätzliche Anforderungen erfüllen, die wohl im Wesentlichen darin bestehen, dass sie zwei Unused Bites in den ganzen Clem Bim noch, oder zwei Unused Werte, also zwei 16-Bit-Werte sind es glaube ich, nochmal in einem Major- und Miner-Number noch zusätzlich reingepackt haben. Also das ist so im Wesentlichen die Aussagekraft, die so ein iBeacon liefern kann.
Ja, das haben irgendwelche Leute reversed. Oder sie haben es halt aus... Naja, wenn du die iBeacon, die Spezifikation selber, wenn du die hast, dann darfst du ja nicht weitergeben, dann bist du ja unter...
Ich hab sowas gehört. Ich bin kein NDR-Unterschrieben.
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Und naja, wie auch immer. Jetzt funken die halt irgendwie so rum. Und, ja genau, wahrscheinlich ist es auch noch so, dass diese iBeacons in ihrem Verhalten außerdem noch einen Wert mitschicken, der etwas über ihre Sendekraft sagt, in ein Meter Entfernung. Und das ist insofern auch ganz eine wertvolle Information, weil du ja ansonsten, du kriegst ja nur die Information, da ist ein iBeacon, du siehst es.
Ja, und wie stark du siehst, empfängst.
Genau, aber ob du das jetzt aus 100 Metern Entfernung gerade mitbekommst oder aus 5, das weißt du halt so nicht. Und das wird eben dadurch quasi noch mehr oder weniger damit reinkodiert, weil du dann eben Empfangsstärken, Messungen machen kannst und das dann in irgendeiner Form in Relation setzen kannst. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie diese iBeacon-Frameworks, die jetzt in iOS 7 drin sind, das jetzt für dich automatisch tun oder nicht.
Ich glaube, du kannst so Radian setzen, nachdem du eine Notification bekommst, wenn du so und so nah dran bist.
Und in iOS 7.1 gibt es jetzt auch noch diese Background-Notification. Das heißt, du kannst dich jetzt für bestimmte iBeacons registrieren und wenn die dann irgendwie auftauchen, dann muss also dein Programm noch nicht mal laufen. Also du hast halt irgendwie eine Notification, die du von dem OS in dem Moment bekommst. Das ist jetzt neu mit 7.1.
Background heißt ja, dein Programm wird aufgeweckt und gestartet, ohne dass es in den Vordergrund kommt.
Ja.
Und du kannst dann die Notification handeln und dich wieder schlafen legen.
Also das scheint jetzt irgendwie mit drin zu sein. Und jetzt kommen irgendwie die Leute wohl langsam gerade mal so auf Ideen. Und da gibt es natürlich so diese Klassiker mit ja, wenn die Leute dann beim Starbucks vorbeilaufen, dann kann sie irgendwie einen Kaffee-Coupon kriegen und ähhh ja genau, ähhh so richtig so.
Die Leute gibt es immer noch?
Das geht auch nicht weg.
Das wird nie weggehen. Haben sie das denn mit Passbook integriert und so? Also ist denn der Coupon dann auch in meinem Passbook drin? Oder wie soll das funktionieren?
Wer hat das jetzt integriert?
Na Apple.
Wer hat es gefunden?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich meine solche Sachen sind natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht sehr naheliegend, dass du jetzt Beacons hast, die einen Ort anzeigen, innenraum, also messen, innenraumbereiche, darum geht es ja im Prinzip.
Da näher von der Kasse?
Ja, Supermärkte, bla, und der ganze Kram. Die Absatzfilme müssen natürlich jetzt allererst noch mal geschrieben werden, aber die Technik ist jetzt da. Und du kannst halt relativ billige Devices kaufen und die dann halt irgendwo verstecken und dann muss deine Software eben das Richtige damit tun. Sprich, du siehst halt die UUID, du kriegst halt eine grobe Information über einen Abstand und dann kannst du halt anfangen, Online-Karten abzurufen, so nach dem Motto, wo ist denn dieses Eyebeacon oder wo soll sich das normalerweise befinden? So und dann kannst du halt, wenn du drei Beacons siehst, da deine Position heraus triangulieren und weißt halt relativ genau, wo du jetzt gerade irgendwie auf einer Messe durch die Stände latscht. Das ist eigentlich so.
Wenn man es selber nicht genau mehr weiß.
Naja, aber ich meine, mit GPS kannst du in so einer Messerhalle halt wenig anfangen. Und du willst es ja an der Stelle wirklich genau wissen.
Das heißt, die Leute, die dich da so einen Beacon aufstellen, die müssen das vorher auch ordentlich einkalibrieren.
Was meinst du damit jetzt?
Na, die müssen ja genau sagen, wo das Ding ist.
Ja, genau. Ich meine, du gehst jetzt von so einem Szenario aus, die Beacons gehören quasi zu deiner Ab. Also angenommen, du bist jetzt eine Messe, und du verteilst jetzt mal ein paar hundert von diesen Teilen quer. Du bist ein Kongress. Genau, 31C3, sagen wir mal konkret. Und du stellst halt an verschiedensten strategischen Orten einfach solche Beacons hin. Und gibst halt eine Datenbankpreis, wo das ist. Und dann kannst du halt eine Ab dafür schreiben, die diese Beacons sieht und diese Datenbank da lutscht. Und dann eben das entsprechend auf einer Karte zuordnet. Und dann kannst du halt sagen, bring mich mal zu was weiß ich, diesem Projekt. Und dann sagt er jetzt, bist du irgendwie Gaderobenfoyer 1, dann bitte jetzt die Rolltreppe hoch und dann rechts durch den langen Flur und dann nochmal die Treppe runter und dann ins Hackcenter rein und da am fünften Tisch. Im Prinzip, also so als Guide. Oder überhaupt, dass du immer siehst, wo bin ich? Was sind denn jetzt hier die Projekte um mich herum?
Wer läuft denn bitte auf dem Kongress mit eingeschaltetem Bluetooth rum? Wer ist denn so bescheuert?
Naja, die 6210-Zeiten sind dann doch rum. Oder war das das 6310i? Keine Ahnung.
Ja, warum sollte man nicht mit eingeschaltetem Bluetooth rumlaufen?
Verbraucht Strom.
Man kriegt iBeacons und das nervt verschwindet, deswegen macht man es demnächst aus. Gutes Training.
Ich habe meinen Bluetooth nie an.
Ja, aber du kannst ja damit auch Spiele machen. Du könntest ja auch so eine richtige Adventure-Hand machen, dass du halt keine Map hast, sondern musst halt irgendwie nur...
Wo ist die Rohrpostkapsel gerade, die man suchen muss?
Ja, du könntest, genau, du könntest iBeacons in... genau.
Wo ist die Post gerade?
Du könntest sozusagen in jedes Teil so einen Beacon reinmachen.
Wenn man sonst nichts zu tun hat.
Auf dem Kongress hat man sonst nichts zu tun.
Also wenn, dann auf dem Kongress, oder?
Ich finde das auf jeden Fall eine ganz spannende Technologie und da geht bestimmt einiges. Und da muss man erstmal auf die richtigen Ideen kommen und das alles miteinander paaren, aber irgendwas machen, was halt weit über Starbucks hinausgeht. Und Maps sind halt das eine und so Dinge finden ist das andere. Also wenn du nicht zu den Dingen kommst, kommen die Dinge zu dir.
Da ist also Silk Road jetzt nicht das schlechteste Beispiel.
Du kannst ja auch solche Big Games spielen. Du kannst ja sozusagen in der Stadt auch mit so Beacons, die durch die Gegend fahren, machen.
Ja, aber so groß ist der Radio natürlich jetzt wieder nicht.
Also da ist nicht irgendwie...
Na ja, mehr als 10 Meter kriegst du mit so einer Beacon nicht hin, oder?
Doch, doch.
Na ja, gut, lass es 30 sein, aber das ist schon schwierig.
Ich hab davon deutlich längeren Empfangswegen gehört. Also das geht schon. Also gerade jetzt Indoor mit Reflektion und Pipapo musst du schon mit verschiedenen Sachen rechnen. Ja, aber damit kann man irgendwie schön rumspielen. Wenn du auf so einer Demo bist irgendwie, und so deine Peer Group, jeder hat irgendwie so einen Beacon dabei, dann kannst du so Crowd Control machen.
Das Interessante an so einer Beacon ist, du steckst die Batterie rein, klebst das Ding an der Wand und musst dich die nächsten drei Jahre nicht darum kümmern, weil das Ding so wenig Strom verbraucht, dass es halt so lange durchhält und einfach biegend. Also das ist irgendwie so...
Erzähl mal was über Atom, bevor ich über ETA renne.
Über Atom, ja, es gibt diesen neuen Browser. Von GitHub.
Der ist nicht so weit weg vom Browser, würde ich sagen.
Vielleicht ist es ein Browser.
Der ist nicht so weit weg vom Browser. Ja, das ist so... Ja, keine Ahnung. Also auf mich macht es so einen Eindruck, als wäre das irgendwie so EMAX 2.0. Also das Teil ist so extrem erweiterbar. Mit irgendwelchen komischen Coffee-Skripten. Und äh... Gleichzeitig leidet da aber meiner Meinung nach der Bedienkomfort drunter.
Also wir erzählen mal kurz, was es ist. Also Atom ist ein Projekt von GitHub.
Ja, das aber noch nicht open source ist.
Noch nicht open source ist, sondern es gibt da noch irgendwie Beta-Invite, alles ganz geheim. Alle wollen einen haben, wollen equalen Kids sein. Ja, und das Ding ist, wie du schon sagtest, in Coffeescript geschrieben. Das sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal betonen. Das ist nämlich ganz interessant.
Ist das komplett in Coffeescript geschrieben?
Soweit ich weiß, ja.
Warum?
Ach.
Das ist ja auf dem Desktop, das ist nicht im Browser.
Also ich meine, warum sagt ihr das jetzt? Was ist so schlimm daran? Nein, nein, Coffeescript. Es compilert zu JavaScript.
Ja, das ist Syntaktik Sugar und JavaScript, oder?
Nein, es ist Syntaktik Stability und JavaScript, weil du in JavaScript einfach so viele Merkwürdigkeiten hast, was so Datentypen und so weiter betrifft.
Wir können uns einigen auf Coffeescript, JavaScript the Good Parts, das ist das dickere Buch, zu JavaScript the Good Parts.
Ja, aber ich finde das sehr interessant, weil im Prinzip JavaScript an dieser Stelle ja betrieben wird wie ein Assembler. Also JavaScript, es gibt ja auch so eine Spekt, so ein reduced JavaScript, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie das heißt, wo man sagt, so hier irgendwie die essentiellen Features von JavaScript, in das du halt deinen Coffeescript oder was auch immer hineinkompilen kannst und damit verhält sich dann quasi JavaScript zu so einer Programmiersprache wie eine Java-VM zu Scala oder Clojure. Ja, aber ich sehe da schon so einen Trend und ich wäre jetzt nicht überrascht, wenn wir noch mehr Programmiersprachen auf dieser Basis sehen werden.
Also umso mehr verschiedene Sorten von so einer Sprache rauskommen, umso größer, also umso beschissener ist doch diese Sprache, weil jeder meint, er müsste es irgendwie noch ein Stück anders machen, weil er ist wohl nicht zufrieden.
Meistens kommen diese Sprachen, die dann oben draufsitzen mit ihren ganz eigenen Problemen nochmal da her. Aber gut, ja, anyway, ist ja auch egal. Haben wir jetzt da drin gemacht.
Genau, was ist hier jetzt so toll an dem Editor?
Das frage ich mich auch ehrlich gesagt. Also er ist sehr stark erweiterbar.
Kannst du das mal zeigen?
Genau, mach doch mal auf den Schirm hier, ich kann mir da nichts vorstellen.
Mach doch mal onscreen hier.
Blackmagic?
Die einzige wahre Frage ist doch, ist er besser als VI?
Da gab es ja dieses lustige Bild. Ah, du kriegst jetzt gleich den Bug, den ich letztens hatte? Das ist der Kontrast-Bug.
Der Kontrast-Bug.
Aber du installierst das jetzt hier schon so als Programm auf dem Mac oder was?
Jaja, das kommt ganz normal gezippt und da fällt dann eine normale App raus und die sieht dann so aus. Also das sind jetzt hier die Settings. So sieht halt...
Bedenken wir sind immer noch ein Audio-Podcast.
Warum eigentlich? Also der normale, der Browser, äh, der Browser. Der Editor sieht aus, wie ein Editor halt so aussieht. Also ich mein, man hat einen Cursor und man kann Tasten tippen. Also das ist jetzt irgendwie... Was ist das denn?
Oder ist das nur wegen, weil du es auch über Airplay auf den Beamer schickst?
Nee. Hier ruckelt es auch.
Ja, verloren.
Wir haben 2014. Geh weg, gib mir mein WI wieder.
Naja, der ist halt super cross-Plattform, obwohl sie bisher nur die Mac-Version rausgebracht haben. Ist mir scheißegal.
Lass mich raten, die haben da ein Webview aufgemacht und starten dann ihr Skript oder was?
Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich finde auch jetzt irgendwie das Syntax-Highlighting nicht besonders. Ich finde den File-Browser nicht besonders. Ich finde an dem Editor eigentlich überhaupt nichts irgendwie besonders.
Was hat er denn vom Editor Features mal abgesehen, wofür ich auch wirklich ein anderes Programm nehmen kann, nämlich das, was man eh schon hat? Was hat er denn für Feature, was es irgendwie speziell für GitHub usable macht?
Ja, er hat irgendeine GitHub-Anbindung. Das Problem ist, dass ich damit auch noch nicht so viel gearbeitet habe und auch gar nicht so genau weiß, was diese ganzen Packages eigentlich tun und wie man sie konfiguriert. Weil einige von den Packages kann man halt so konfigurieren, wie sie sind. Und andere Packages muss man dann irgendwie aber über Settings-Files konfigurieren und so weiter.
Ach so, ja, hier man... Ist das jetzt? Oh man, ich sehe es schon. Also ich bin da wahrscheinlich jetzt hier... Okay, also der config-file.cson scheint so eine Art Coffee-Script Jason zu sein. Ja, da kann man halt... Ja, ist wie Jason mit weniger Klammern, wenn ich das so sehe. Kann man halt irgendwelche Einstellungen... Also ich bin wirklich underwhelmed, muss ich sagen. Also das ist so... Okay, es ist auch...
Ich glaube, wir sind auch die falsche Zielgruppe, Roddy.
Das ist auch ein Easy-Round-Target irgendwie, weil ich meine, so Cross-Plattformen und so, das ist so...
Das ist für die hippen Web-Developer-Kids gemacht.
Ja, das bin ich natürlich nicht. Also keine Ahnung, ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass der irgendwas kann, was nicht Schokolade schon besser kann. Oder sogar Textmeet 2. Ja gut, mit dem habe ich jetzt nicht so viel Erfahrung. Oder so Sachen wie... Da habe ich jetzt irgendwie ein XML-File aufgemacht, was irgendwie nicht eingerückt war.
Was macht das Ding, wenn du 200 Megabyte Text-File draufgiehst?
Weiß ich nicht, hast du meins da?
Ich schon, aber nicht auf deinem Computer.
Naja, hier, AirDrop.
Spot macht das dann. Spinning-Pizza auf das.
Irgendwie bin ich hier gerade im Super-Retina-Modus.
Super-Retina.
Ja, dropp mir doch mal was.
Hast du keine Lockfights auf der Platte? Doch.
Hast du ein Farbmanagementsystem bei dir an? Mit abends dunkler machen und so weiter? Weil irgendwie sieht es da bei dir komisch aus, Roddy.
Na, ich hab's halt auf hell gemacht. Moment mal.
Nee, nee, es ist nicht nur hell. Nur da, wo der Schatten ist, kann man sehen, dass da noch andere Farben existieren. Das ist irgendwie... Saturation ist bei dir irgendwie voll im Auge. Voll im gesamten Screen.
Achso, nee, das ist sein Beamer. Da kann ich nichts für. Ich komm mit dem Ding nicht klar.
Ja gut, ich mein, wenn du das erste Mal vor dem Wim sitzt, dann kommst du damit auch nicht klar, ne? Also das... das ist ja... Das ist ja ganz normal.
Das ist ganz normal, okay.
Aber bei mir gehen Alarmglocken an, wenn es in JavaScript oder CoffeeScript und wahrscheinlich mit irgendwelchen Webviews gemacht ist.
Aber es stimmt, es ist noch gar nicht aufgefallen, dass der wirklich richtig langsam ist. Und das irgendwie bei Last Generation Rechner...
Das ist dir nicht aufgefallen.
Na gut, gib mir doch jetzt mal eine Datei, eine große.
Jason, ein großes Jason ist immer der...
Obwohl, hier. Also es gibt hier noch Dark-Themes und so. Ui-Theme. Du bist immer noch nicht im Airdrop übrigens, ne?
Entschuldigung, ich hab keinen Airdrop auf diesem Computer.
So sieht das dann in Dunkel aus? Wenn ich dich da schon so klicken sehe.
Also da müsste man jetzt mal ein eins zu eins Vergleich machen. Dann nehmen wir zum Beispiel so was wie Sublime Text danebenhalten, was so von den Texteditoren so die Performance Bombe ist. Da ist alles einfach instantan geklickt, Sublime Text ist einer der schnellsten Editoren überhaupt. Und wenn ich das dagegen halten würde, dann würde das wahrscheinlich so... Ja, aber Sublime Text ist zum Beispiel extrem schlecht beim Öffnen von großen Dateien. Also das ist jetzt genau das, was ich in letzter Zeit hier getestet habe. Wenn du mal so 200 MB SQL-Dump draufwürfst, dann ist das Sublime. Und der Wim? Der lädt da einfach eeeewig das Sublime. Na gut, aber ansonsten ist das schnell. Dann wird der wahrscheinlich auch total abkacken.
Wenn du 200 MB SQL-Dump in deinen Editor schmeißt, dann hast du eh was falsch gemacht. Sortiert mal vorher weg, was man braucht. Du willst mir nicht sagen, du liest ja 200 MB durch. Was willst du denn mit dem im Editor?
Na, nach Informationen suchen? Ich habe aber nicht in SQL, sondern ich habe das Dump. Und ich suche in dem Dump eine alte Information, weil das ein Backup ist. Grep? Natürlich kann ich Grep benutzen. Es geht ja nicht darum, dass ich was anderes nehme. Ja, ich habe verschiedene Editoren hier getestet. Aber da scheitern sehr viele dran an sowas. Ja, und es gibt aber auch welche, die sind hervorragend. Also zum Beispiel Text Static ist super rasant. Beschwert sich überhaupt nicht. Text-Mate sagt Out of Memory. Sublime sagt, warte mal drei Minuten, dann mache ich die auf. Aber macht das Syntax-Highlighting? Ich kann ja bei Text Static nicht so viel sagen. Aber hat das bunt gemacht oder hat das einfach nur angezeigt? Weil wenn du Syntax-Highlighting ausmachst oder das als Plain Text lätst, dann können das die anderen auch. Das ist ein guter Punkt. Das muss ich mal ausprobieren. Also kannst du die Dateienung mal nach.txt oder sowas machen? Dann könnte es vielleicht funktionieren. Ich check das mal. Aber diese Syntax-Highlighter, die sind meistens die, die dann total ins Stottern kommen. Aber wie das? Iiiih, ist das langsam.
Iiiih.
Das ist ja furchtbar.
Hab ich jetzt einen Text? Ich hab keinen Text.
Was ich dachte, als ich davon gehört hab, dass GitHub ein Editor hat, ist, dass du den im Web direkt da auf der Seite bedient kannst. Am besten Projekt, wo ich nicht mal geforkt habe, geh ich hin, mach ne Änderung, sag Pull Request und ich muss nix clonen, nix, gar nix, sondern ist gleich alles online. Also für so Schreibfehler, Syntax Errors und so, da ist doch... da muss man ja nicht clonen. Da kann man das schnell mal online machen. Das hätte ich gedacht, wäre das.
Aber das haben sie doch eh schon, dass du da im Web-Interface direkt auf Edit klicken kannst.
Haben sie?
Sogar mit Syntax-Highlighting.
Also scrollen ist jetzt auch nicht das...
Das Thema trägt jetzt nicht mehr. Wir haben keine Ahnung und...
Und scheiße, das ist es auch noch.
Ein viel zu langsamer Rechner hier.
Wir sind nicht überzeugt.
Nee, also ich meine es ist ja auch immer noch eine Beta. Vielleicht holen sie ja noch irgendwie Magic... Magic Magic jetzt irgendwie Performance raus.
Sagen sie sich um ihre Webseite kümmern, statt Editoren in irgendwelchen... nicht derartigen Programmiersprachen zu schreiben.
Also bei mir ist es so, der Editor-Test immer, kann der Editor mir ein XML reformatieren, so dass man das auch irgendwie... dass es wenigstens halbwegs human readable ist. Und mir ist irgendwie... Ich hab das nicht gefunden, ob es dafür einen Befehl gibt. Also es war so...
Na ja, das ist jetzt aber auch ein relativ einseitiger Test. Du bist so einseitig.
Ja, das mag ja sein. Aber wenn das jetzt so mein Use-Case ist und er deckt die nicht ab, dann ist halt doof. Also es gibt irgendwie auch so eine Markdown-Preview-Ansicht, die nicht funktioniert hat bei mir. Und es ist alles irgendwie underwhelming.
Ja, also Texttastic macht Syntax-Highlighting und macht hier so ein 200 MB SQL-File mal eben... Das heißt aber Text-Tastic. Text-Tastic, genau. Ist das so ein Editor, bei dem relativ wenig geredet wird?
Ja, kann auch keiner aussprechen.
Text-Tastic.
Was das ausmacht, wenn man was nicht aussprechen kann.
Ja, aber der ist schnell und einfach. Also den könnt ihr euch gerne auch mal anschauen. Ich hab jetzt noch nicht so sehr viel damit gearbeitet. Mir ist er neulich überhaupt erst mal aufgefallen, als ich dieses Ich öffne diese Dateiproblem hatte. Weil vorher wollte ich mich eigentlich mit ZappLime ein bisschen anfreunden, hab das auch ein bisschen getan und dann hab ich die Datei geöffnet und dachte mir nur so... Ja, also ich meine, ich kann dir das hier gerne mal demonstrieren, wie das aussieht, wenn ich hier... Ist das der ZappLime Text 2 oder 3 oder... 2. Gibt's da schon einen mehr? Ich glaube, es gibt schon einen mehr. Das ist aber Beta, glaube ich. Die Betas von ZappLime, die sind gut. So, Open und dann macht ihr ein großes schwarzes Fenster auf und seht ihr diese dünne Linie hier? Das ist der Progress Bar hier in der Mitte. Dieses dünne Teil.
Die hat jetzt geschätzt 3% oder was?
Ja, das geht jetzt hier über die ganze Bildschirmpreite. Aber man weiß, wie geil das SQL dann hinterher aussieht. Also vielleicht ist das ja auch wirklich... Also schöner hätte man es dann auch gar nicht mehr anzeigen können. Und dann ist es Full Text Index, die 200 MB, und du kannst da drin suchen und finden und editieren und validieren und... Texttastic, der übrigens hier im Hintergrund auch gerade mit 200% CPU am Werke ist. Wahrscheinlich weil er das einfach irgendwie alles im Hintergrund macht. Genau, der erinnert erstmal die ersten paar Zeilen. Genau, der ist nämlich immer noch dabei, aber der macht das halt asynchron. Also er öffnet einfach schneller.
Ja, aber asynchron, der macht es halt aber auch trotzdem da, wo du gerade gar nicht bist und wenn du irgendwo hingehst, wo er noch nicht Syntex-Coloring gemacht hat, dann hört er an den anderen Stellen nicht auf und macht das schnell mal da, wo du bist. Das tut er auch nicht. Also so gesehen...
Vielleicht...
Na ja, sieht man doch. Sonst würde er jetzt woanders wo er jetzt aufhören und sofort den Ausschnitt hier...
Ja, aber guck dir mal die Responsiveness an von dem Ding hier. Hoch, runter, hoch, runter... Der marschiert richtig ab. Also, während ich hier weiß, was da bleibt, noch mal kurz rüber schalte.
Geschätzt 15 Prozent jetzt, oder?
Ja, und vor allem so modal und irgendwie so... Nichts geht und... Ja, und Tex Marte wirft irgendwann sich vom Pferd, wenn es zu groß ist, dann sagt er irgendwie Error und dem scheinen hier irgendwie so solche Limits nicht viel auszumachen. Also, keine Ahnung, was er sonst noch so kann, aber ich werde ihn jetzt mal häufiger benutzen, weil ich stehe einfach auf schnell und responsive. Also, das ist einfach mal ein gutes Zeichen für gute Programmierung, wenn Dinge responsiv sind.
Ich bin ja immer auch der Meinung, dass die ganzen Courses in meinem Rechner nicht ordentlich genutzt werden. Das ist total schlimm. Leute, die heutzutage Programme bauen, sollen mal ihr Grunddesign ihrer Programme so machen, dass es gleich auf mehreren Courses irgendwie Erlang-mäßig einfach von Hause aus heutzutage gehen muss. Also jeder, der was Neues anfängt, wenn das nicht auf mehreren CPUs läuft, kann man da eigentlich gleich in die Tonne treten. Mit Anlauf.
Das ist unter Coco inzwischen auch nicht mehr so schwierig.
Eben. Grand Central und dann geht es ab. Das ist echt.
So, jetzt sind wir schon fast beim Thema.
Ach, jetzt sind wir beim Thema.
Ich will jetzt mal ein Thema einschieben. Ich will auch mal wieder Themen einschieben. Sehr schön, mach das.
Obwohl es jetzt gerade so schön gepasst hätte.
So, wir haben jetzt hier 1092, ne? Und nachdem es draußen war, hat man auch schon drüber geredet, ja schon lange, ist auch egal. Aber dann kamen auch schon gleich die ersten Betas, halt halt, von 1093. Und bisher war ja so, dass zwar Apple schon ein bisschen 4K-Zeugs-Werbung, Tra-La-La macht und so weiter, Support, aber da hat man nur, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, weil ich hab so einen Monitor nicht, man hat nur 30 Hertz. Also es ist mehr so zu betrachten von irgendwas als zum Schnell, also zocken zum Beispiel 30 Hertz, kannste ja mal voll vergessen.
Kommt darauf an, was du spielst.
Was ich spiele, braucht mehr als 30 Hertz. Nee, so schnell kann ich nicht gucken. Nee, aber ich brauch so einen, wie heißen die Dinger? FPS, so einen First-Person-Shooter. Frames per second auch. Da brauchst du einfach alles in schnell schnell. Jedenfalls das neueste 10.9.3 Beta, da ist jetzt besserer Support für 4K-Displays. Und zwar erstens hast du jetzt bei mehreren Modellen auch die 60 Hz, also die supporten das jetzt richtig. Und außerdem hast du auch den Retina-Support für so ein 4K-Display. Das heißt, du kannst einstellen, dass du da die volle Größe haben willst, oder größer oder kleiner, und dann macht der da virtuell Bilder mit 5000 oder 6000 Breite und skaliert dir dann wieder auf 4K-Display passend runter. Also das nächste Update 10.9.3 halt wird Leute mit dicken Monitoren sehr viel Spaß machen.
Das können sie auch gerne für den normalen 27er freischalten. Da bin ich auch nichts gegen.
Das Retina? Den Retina Support, oder was meinst du?
Ob das nun Retina heißt oder nicht? Ich meine, da ist ein Pixel und der geht so oder so damit um. Er kann halt eine größere Pixelzahl nehmen und die da drauf runter skalieren.
Ja, aber das macht ja bei deinem keinen Sinn, weil du hast ja gerade so viele, beim 4K macht es ja Sinn, weil die Skalierung dann halt nicht mehr zu sehen ist, weil er so fein ist.
Das ist so auch nicht zu sehen. Siehst du auf diesem Bildschirm gerade irgendeinen Pixel einzeln?
Alter, ich sitze hier drei Meter weg.
Eben, und wenn ich da einen Meter von wegsetze, ist mir doch auch scheißegal.
Ja, dann brauchst du aber auch nichts hochskalieren, wenn du so weit wechseln, um das dann wieder runter zu skalieren.
Na doch, Tim hat ja schlechte Augen. Hab ich mehr Platz, ich hab gute Augen.
Ja, muss man ausprobieren, 1093 ist das Stichwort.
Ich dachte, wir installieren keine Beta-Version.
Ich hab doch nichts installiert, ich lese das nur da. Ich bin im Netcast-Org, weil die reden über Grafikkarten, die eigentlich nicht in so einen Mac reingehören. Die probieren wir alles Mögliche aus. Auch letztens haben sie festgestellt, dass die NVIDIA Titan-Karte, das ist eine ziemlich fette Karte, die hat auch 1000 Euro gekostet, die kostet jetzt ein paar Hundert Euro weniger. Das ist eine ziemlich fette Karte. Wenn man den Treiber von NVIDIA nicht vom OS X-System nimmt, sondern bei denen auf der Webseite runterlädt, dann läuft die Karte auch. Das ist wohl schneller als so ziemlich alles andere, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Aber sie sind da sehr viel mit Grafikkarten rumspielen. Die testen auch immer gleich, wenn in jeder Beta die neuesten Grafikkarten treiben usw. Da sehe ich immer sowas. Die sind dann mal schnell am Start. Ich glaube, bei dem Fireball-Typie heute, dem Gruber, da war heute auch was da drüber. Der hat irgendeinen verlinkt. Ich glaube Ars Techniker hat was drüber geschrieben, bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher. Naja, das wollte ich mal vergehen haben. Oder die, ja genau. Es wird auch Zeit. Ich warte ja immer noch, bis Apple mal ein 4K-Display rausbringen mit Sander, wie heißt das inzwischen? Sander Bowl, Sander Dingens und das im Display gleich Ethernet drin ist. Das hätte ich gerne. Dann würde ich mal eventuell über den Kauf eines Displays nachdenken, aber solange das nicht am Start ist, können sie behalten.
Tim, hier noch für die Runde kurz, kannst du mal auf den Link klicken im Chat? Das war noch die Zusammenfassung zu dem Atomeditor.
Ja, ich finde den Mac und den PC sehr schön.
Hi, I'm Vim. Hi, I'm Emacs sozusagen. Dann kommt Atom und wird zusammengestarrt.
Ja, aber nicht, dass wir jetzt hier Atom zusammengeschlagen hätten.
Nein, das war nur das Kommentar, was dann hängen blieb irgendwie in kollektivem Gedächtnis der ewigen, allwissenden Müllhalde. So, ich wollte jetzt mal eine prinzipielle Diskussion los treten.
Ui, jetzt noch! Das ist zum Beispiel die prinzipielle Frage, was ist mit der Schokolade hier eigentlich?
Die Frage ist, wie lange dauert es noch, bis die Schokolade hier sein wird? Ja, warum gibt es sowas nicht wie Calle Schocky oder so?
Gerade hier bei dir im hipsten Prenzelberg. Du kannst ja zum nächsten Mal bei Schocky was bestellen. Alle versagen. Okay, du wolltest was Prinzipielles klären.
Ich wollte euch fragen, wie ihr das so seht, weil ich entweder irgendwas habe ich verpasst.
Um was geht es denn eigentlich? Ich glaube, der Hörer weiß noch nicht, was du hier noch meinst.
Niemand, ihr wisst das auch noch nicht. Es geht um ETA. Es geht um Estimated Time of Arrival.
Also die berühmten Apple-Minuten meinst du?
Ja, unter anderem die Apple-Minuten. Aber eigentlich auch alle anderen Minuten. Weil ich kann mich einfach nicht erinnern, dass ich in den letzten 30 Jahren mal irgendeine Software gefunden habe, die mir auch nur halbwegs irgendwie das Gefühl gibt, sie kann mir eine verlässliche Aussage darüber treffen, wann irgendetwas fertig ist. Und das liegt teilweise auch so ein bisschen an der Schwierigkeit, solche Dinge vorherzusagen, weil sich halt die Parameter, die das beeinflussen, wie lange es dauert, auch am laufenden Meter ändern. Aber ihr kennt das zum Beispiel.
Wie Karl Valentin so schön sagte, Voraussagen sind immer schwierig, besonders wenn sie die Zukunft betreffen.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber trotzdem sitzt man häufig daneben, schaut sich an, was so angezeigt wird, und denkt sich, das kann nicht sein. Also der Klassiker ist so. Du hast so eine Software, die lädt was runter. So ein FTP-Klein. Und dann hast du da irgendwie viele Bites. Und am Anfang dauert es irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Weil, keine Ahnung, Verbindungen müssen aufgebaut werden, Modems müssen wählen.
Weil sich das TCP-Winn erstmal vergrößern muss.
Und dann passiert auch irgendwas ganz Schwerwiegendes. Dinge dauern und es gibt irgendwie ein riesen Problem. Und das Ding geht irgendwie hoch auf, ja, das dauert jetzt noch eine Stunde. Also wenn es so weitergeht, dann dauert es zehn Stunden.
Die Ansätze kannst du selber mal belegen.
Und wenn es so weitergeht, dann dauert es 20 Stunden. Und ich verstehe das ja auch alles, weil jetzt irgendwie 50 Bites runtergeladen. Und da müssen halt irgendwie 400 MB runtergeladen werden. Also wenn ich jetzt in der Geschwindigkeit weiter lade, dann wird aber der Staudamm gelöst.
Und dann geht es plötzlich voll schnell. Da steht aber immer noch vier Stunden.
Ja, dann ist es halt schon auf drei Stunden. Und dann ist es auf, ja, also echt, das geht ja jetzt so rasant. Dann sind es ja noch zwei Stunden. Und eigentlich erst in den letzten zehn Sekunden kriegst du irgendwie so einen Halbwegs brauchbaren Wert. Aber du sitzt die ganze Zeit daneben und du weißt ganz genau, es ist einfach mal anders. So, und die Frage ist jetzt eigentlich, wenn man jetzt ein ETA-Window macht, also wenn man sozusagen so ein Estimated Time of Arrival irgendwie macht, was sollte der Algorithmus sein, der diese Zeit festlegt? Ich meine, ich würde so herangehen, dass ich auf der einen Seite natürlich errechne, was es bisher an Zeit verbraucht und was es bisher an Daten übergeben worden ist. Aber man sollte halt nicht immer das Gesamte betrachten, sondern man sollte sozusagen auch immer ein kleineres Zeitfenster, was den aktuellen Fluss in irgendeiner Form besser berücksichtigt, damit reinnehmen. Warum macht das keiner?
Also um zu wissen, wie viel Zeit noch gebraucht wird, ist ja schon, dass das Programm erst mal wissen muss, wie viel Zeit es grundsätzlich, also beim Runterladen jetzt, wie viel es grundsätzlich braucht, um eine gewisse Menge an Daten zu benutzen. Du nutzt natürlich die Menge, die es schon runtergeladen hat und die passende Zeit dazu. Was die halt aber machen, ist, wenn er schon eine Minute was runtergeladen hat, dann nimmt er die komplette letzte Minute und macht darüber den Durchschnitt. Das ist natürlich aber eigentlich scheiße, weil eigentlich willst du die letzten paar Sekunden sehr hochgewicht, also wichten. Aber das, was vor einer Minute gewesen ist, das willst du vielleicht auch wichten, aber sehr, sehr wenig. Und das machen die natürlich nicht. Aber ich kann schon auch verstehen, wenn einer da so ein simples Download-Tool schreibt, dass er da keinen Bock hat da erstmal ein Semester in Statistik oder was auch immer zu belegen.
Du kannst doch mal eine Library schreiben.
Du musst doch keine Statistik machen dafür. Ja, aber das erklärt auch andere Effekte nicht, die selbst die Superfirma Apple immer wieder drauf hat, dass gerade am Ende hin, dass das einigermaßen so hinkommt, wenn du so Mavericks installierst oder so was, dann macht das so 99 Prozent, sagt ja nicht Prozent, sondern so, in einer Minute sind wir fertig. Also es hat schon eigentlich alle die Macht laut seinem Balken. Und diese eine Minute dauert dann 20. Der Feine hat mir auch schon gesagt, dass er in minus fünf Minuten dann fertig ist.
Am besten fand ich ja immer diesen Flash-Installer, der diesen Balken gemacht hat. Und dann wollte er aber noch irgendwie das Administrator-Passwort. Und der Balken bewegte sich aber schon los. Und wenn man das Passwort nicht eingegeben hat, dann hat sich der Balken bis 95 Prozent bewegt. Und erst, wenn man das Passwort eingegeben hat, dann hat er irgendwas gemacht. Und irgendwann einfach die letzten fünf Minuten zack.
Er hat halt geschummelt, um dir das Gefühl zu geben, dass da was Wichtiges passiert. Das sieht man auch ganz oft, die Schummeln beim Progress Bar. Der steigt einfach so.
Oder bei der Bahn, die Automaten, der geht dann, der Progress Bar läuft super voll. Und wenn er dann voll ist, dann ist er wieder leer. Und läuft nochmal voll. Und läuft nochmal voll.
Die beste ETA-Anzeige ist keine ETA-Anzeige. Die sollen einfach sagen, wie viel Prozent fertig ist. Und du in deinem Kopf starrend auf diese Prozent-Anzeige oder auf den Progress Bar machst du ja deine ETA-Szene. Aber wie soll die sagen einfach dann gleich?
Das hat keine Zeitrelation.
Der Progress Bar hat keine Zeitachse. Aber wozu dein Anzeigen? Ja, dass du einfach weißt, es geht voran.
Also, dass es überhaupt Bewegung ist, dass es überhaupt Dinge...
Also, weil es dann da stehen bleibt.
Mal mal, er bleibt jetzt eine Stunde lang stehen.
Dann würdest du vielleicht denken, das kann ich vielleicht abbrechen. Irgendetwas läuft da nicht weiter. Aber wenn er sich immer so ein bisschen weiter bewegt oder die Prozente hochzählt und jetzt mach ich dies und jetzt mach ich das oder, weißt du, einfach so Arbeitsschritte anzeigen und du hast ein Gefühl für Fortschritt, ja? Aber gar nicht dir die Illusionen geben, gar nicht versuchen, dir zu erzählen zu wollen, wie lange das jetzt dauern wird. Also, ich finde erst mal, man müsste sowas auch komplett grafisch lösen können, ohne jetzt irgendwelche komischen Zahlen anzeigen zu können. Man muss sozusagen, das bisher erreichte, muss man sicherlich irgendwie abbilden. Aber man muss auch irgendwie die aktuelle Fluptizität abbilden. Ja, die Fluptizität.
Ich würde sagen, auch weniger Information sind mehr Information in dem Fall.
Also ich finde es voll in Ordnung, wie Microsoft das macht, wo dann steht, Update 7 von 98 wird installiert. Da weißt du doch, woran du bist. Der Echner wird hinterher automatisch ausgeschaltet.
Wenn er mit den 98 durch ist und sich bootet, entdeckt er, dass er ja leider auch 54 vergessen hat. Wenn er die durch hat und sich bootet, dann entdeckt er, dass er noch zu 23 vergessen hat.
Der Echner wird ja dann ausgeschaltet.
Aber Safari kann man auch sehen, dass er schummelt. Wenn Safari nämlich der blaue Balken um so ein bisschen kommt und dann das eigentlich steht, wenn man denn derzeit sein Fenster in der Größe verändert und so ein bisschen mit der Maus im Kreis dreht, dann wird der Balken auch immer mehr. Ja, und zwar nur, wenn man die Maus bewegt.
Hier wird gerade ein schönes passendes XKCD zu dem Thema eingeworfen. Ich bin gerade außerhalb der Stadt, also sollte ich in 15 Minuten da sein. The author of the Windows File Copy Dialog visits some friends. Ja, so und... Ich hab's nie wirklich so nachprogrammiert, aber meiner Meinung nach sollte man quasi mehrere Betrachtungsfenster mit unterschiedlichen Gewichtungen damit reinbringen. Also man muss immer schauen, wie läuft's jetzt gerade, was ist sozusagen in den letzten 10 Prozent passiert und die Gesamtbetrachtung. Nee, nicht separat anzeigen, sondern das eben in so ein Estimate reinschreiben.
Aber für welchen Job meinst du denn jetzt?
Ich will wissen, wie lange muss ich auf die Scheiße noch warten?
Welche Scheiße?
Welche Scheiße auch immer.
Nee, aber das Warte-Warte. Also zum Beispiel gibt's ja eine Sache, du kopierst einen Fall, sagen wir mal, ist ein Gigabyte groß, dann ist der Job klar, du musst einen Gigabyte gleichmäßig wegschreiben. Dann gibt's aber den Fall, du hast ganz, ganz viele Files. Davon sind vielleicht zwei, drei ganz groß, aber der Rest ist ganz, ganz klein. Das ist wieder eine ganz andere Arbeit auf einer Festplatte als auf einer SSD. Nee, das ist alles anders. Ich meine, du kannst ja gar nicht wissen, wie lange das ungefähr dauert. Dann weißt du nicht, wie die Platte zersplittet.
Dann kommt ein Cronjob dazwischen.
Genau, also so richtig genau eins zu eins geht es nicht. Da ist fast was auf dem Internet runterladen noch das Einfachste.
Alles kann länger dauern als gedacht, aber die Realität ist, alles dauert länger als gedacht. Ja, aber trotzdem ist es so, dass die meisten Dinge sich in der Regel schon in etwa abschätzen lassen, wenn man die Informationen hat. Die Informationen hat aber nur das Programm. Und ich als User bin davon abhängig, dass das Programm mir diese Informationen korrekt durchleitet. Da ist mir in der Regel nicht alle Messwerte weiterreichs, wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal alle ermittelt. Das prangere ich auch an. Deswegen, die Fluptizität muss einfach da drin sein. Er kann ja sehen, rauschen jetzt die Daten gerade rein, rauschen sie kontinuierlich rein, ist jetzt gerade richtig hier was im Gange, dann ist es doch klar, dass man nicht mehr sagt, es dauert wahrscheinlich noch acht Tage, weil er irgendwie eine Minute für die ersten zehn Bits gebraucht hat. Wie findest du das Estimation-Ding von Transmission?
Wollte ich gerade sagen, da ist es eigentlich ganz cool. Der Ai hat aber dafür auch die ganze Zeit hin und her und ist sich auch nicht sicher, wie lange er braucht.
Ja, gerade so Pfeilsachen und so, da kann es einem halt schon mal passieren, dass da mal wieder ein Paket durchkommt.
Ich glaube bei Bitcoins ist das so eine relativ gute, hast du jetzt recht. Tim hat nicht für Open Source Software den donated.
Du musst erst einen anklicken, sonst kommt da nichts. Klick mal eins an, genau da drin, eins anklicken.
Ja, die sind ja hier alle irgendwie oil. Ich benutze eigentlich derzeit eher diesen BitTorrent-Client.
Wie das Original von Bram Cohn.
Also diesen U-Torrent da.
Micro-Torrent heißt es.
My-Torrent.
Micro.
Micro-Torrent, Micro-Torrent. Ja, den fand ich irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen toller, weil er mir irgendwelche Daten angezeigt hat, aber ich weiß nicht mehr genau welche. Keine Ahnung, ich hab da mehrfach hin und her gewechselt. Also jetzt wo du es gerade sagst, bei BitTorrent sind die Estimates irgendwie manchmal gefühlt besser. Aber warum jetzt einfach so normale Kopiervorgänge immer so schwach?
Dafür springt er aber auch hin und her und ist sich nie so sicher. Der zeigt eigentlich mehr oder weniger immer die Geschwindigkeit, also basierend auf der Geschwindigkeit, die er gerade hat und berücksichtigt aber nicht was vorher gewesen ist.
Das ist nämlich das andere Extrem, was ich auch häufig sehe. Also entweder sind sie vollständig auf das, was gerade passiert, fixiert oder eben auf diese Gesamtansicht. Und ich denke, man sollte mal darüber nachdenken, da so eine generische Gewichtung für diese Vorgänge zu machen.
Das ist ein Slider, wo die Leute sagen können, wie ihre ETA berechnet wird. So mehr langsichtig oder mehr kurzfristig berechnet.
Die normative Kraft ist faktisch. Ja, und ich glaube, dass es durchaus möglich ist, dass du da so eine Art selbstfühlendes System machst, in dem du halt so die Differenzen aus verschiedenen Werten generierst.
Was man eigentlich haben will, ist, dass man das System selber lernt, was man am Anfang sagt, was später dabei rauskommt und je nachdem soll er immer so einen Offset-Faktor in seine Voraussagen mit einberechnen.
Ich sehe schon, Lib ETA, jetzt auf GitHub.
Ja, das wär's doch.
Wollen wir mal schätzen, wann sie da ist? Das ist gerade nicht mehr lange gedauert. Und doch, nee doch, noch ein paar Jahre wahrscheinlich. Wie würdest du den Algorithmus schreiben für das Ende dieser Sendung? Wobei, ich sehe da gerade die vier Stunden schon anrauschen.
Aber es ist eigentlich eine easy Sache für einen Programmierer. Bei lib.eta, man muss keinen GUI schreiben, das ist schon mal eine gute Sache.
CoffeeScript irgendwie geht ganz schnell, ohne Klammern.
Genau, die M-E-T-A. Muss man sich nur noch einen JavaScript CoffeeScript-Compiler irgendwie an den Start bringen.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es eine Wikipedia-Seite, dass alles ganz wissenschaftlich voll kompliziert und komplex ist. Und da gibt es mehrere Studien, die sind alle noch nicht beendet und es dauert noch 20 Jahre.
Ok, aber ihr seht zumindest ein, dass es durchaus ein Thema ist, über das man sich mal Gedanken machen sollte.
Da machen wir uns schon seit 20 Jahren Gedanken und haben es aufgegeben.
Die M-E-T-A-Ebene.
Unser ETA ist definitiv jetzt auch langsam erreicht. Der ETD ist jetzt erreicht. Erreicht mich gerade ein lustiger Tweet tatsächlich. Breaking. Ich fand den ganz putzig. 18,5 Millionen Euro, oder wie wir im Bistum sagen, einmal Bart fließen bitte, sagt T. Barts von Elst. Wobei es ja 27 sind, da kann man noch eine vergoldete Klosche da reinstellen. Tja, man weiß jetzt nicht, ob man sich über Priester oder über Fußballvereinvorsitzende mehr aufgeben soll.
Das sind einfache Ziele. So quasi das Microsoft unter dem Hänger. Den Boulevard-Themen.
Roddy, nachdem wir deine ganzen zurückgestellten Themen der letzten Sendung jetzt auch schon alle wieder zurückgestellt haben. Du wolltest dich hier nochmal rechtfertigen?
Ja, das, was ich das letzte Mal über Woynich erzählt habe und diesem Typ, der versucht hat, das zu entschlüsseln, das hat nicht lange auf sich warten lassen. Da haben die ersten Leute ihn gnadenlos zerlegt.
Wie dich oder ihn?
Ihn? Ja, mich auch so ein bisschen. Aber vor allen Dingen ihn. Ich hab mir das dann noch mal näher angeguckt. Je länger man sich damit befasst, desto faszinierender wird das. Aber das machen wir vielleicht irgendwann mal anders. Oder das soll mal jemand episch auswalzen, der sich schon länger damit beschäftigt hat. So ganz einfach ist das nicht. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass wir in den nächsten Jahren eine Entschlüsselung davon sehen werden. Aber das Einzige, was ich vielleicht noch kurz sagen könnte, ist dieser Mail-Pilot. Das ist ein ganz witziges Mail-Programm. Das kann zwar vieles, also was heißt witzig? Es ist ganz gut, um Mails zu sortieren. Das ist ein Mail-Programm. Mail-Pilot heißt es?
Ja, auf welchem Betriebssystem läuft das denn?
Auf unserem. Auf Mac OS gibt es leider nicht auf iOS. Und zwar ist es gefühlt kein kompletter Mail-Client, weil ein richtiger Mail-Client muss noch mehr können als das, was das kann. Aber das ist sehr gut geeignet, um schnell reinkommende Mails wegzusortieren. Und zu sagen, hier Delete oder hier, ja ist gut, rein ins Archiv, immer nur einen Tastendruck.
So für Telekom-Hotline-Mitarbeiter.
Ja, genau, oder erinnere mich in drei Tagen noch mal dran. Oder pack das mal in die und die Liste und so. Also dafür finde ich das relativ schön, weil der dann auch mal guckt, was habe ich jetzt wegsortiert, was habe ich noch nicht wegsortiert und so.
Was ist denn jetzt? Mein Tweet ist mal wieder retweetet worden.
Der von dem du nicht weißt, warum er retweetet wird?
Ja, mein super Tweet. Der ist jetzt wieviel Tage alt. Wo steht denn das? Hier steht nur ein Datum.
Also das Ding, das ist, dieses Mailpilot stürzt relativ oft ab. Kann kein Pop 3, gut Pop 3 ist jetzt auch Geschichte, aber... Ja, finde ich.
Ja, ist so.
Hat irgendwie, hat Probleme mit Attachments, die inline anzuzeigen, hat, ja, ist auch sonst so. Aber wie gesagt, zum Sortieren von Mails, wie sie reinkommen, einfach mal so in Box, wenigstens mal so in die Nähe von Zero kriegen, dafür ist es ziemlich gut geeignet. Kann ich dafür echt empfehlen.
Nun ist ja immer noch Postbox, aber leider ist das jetzt mittlerweile wohl Abandonware. Gibt es keine Updates mehr?
Ja, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob Mailpilot nicht inzwischen auch Abandonware ist. Die sind da irgendwie zwar erst vor einigen wenigen Monaten gestartet, aber die Situation wird einfach nicht besser. Also das Teil, besonders wenn ich den Rechner schlafen lege und mach ihn, weg ihn wieder aus, auf dem Schlaf, wer ist weg? Mailpilot.
Ja, es ist einfach Mail-Software hat es irgendwie schwer. Ja, aber es gibt irgendwie gefühlt mehr Mail-Klines für Mac OS X, als es ordentliche Microblogging-Klines gibt. 904 Tage alt ist mein Tweet. Super-Tweet! Und was war es nochmal? Na, ich kann ihn ja mal in den Chat schmeißen.
Supergeil.
Super-Tweet.
Superm.
Ich dachte, das haben die dann geraucht. Ich dachte, als ich das gesehen habe, was haben die denn geraucht?
Ich kann's dir jetzt nicht geben. Ich und er haben dies geraucht.
Und nur 10 Jahre später, oder wie?
Ne, das haben ich und er gemacht.
Für Edeka.
Die haben jetzt schon vorher ein Video mit dem gemacht. Und das war sozusagen noch so eine Adaption für Edeka. 1823 Ried-Tweets. Lois, tut mal was hier für mein Ego.
Kannst ja voll vergessen.
Ich will die 2000 knacken. Ich fand's aber trotzdem gut. Was? Super gut. Super geil. Was denn? Wo hast du das reingepackt? Mailpilot fandst du gut oder was?
Nee, super geil.
Ach, super geil? Ja, die fährst du schon vor Monaten auf eines FW. Wo denn? Ach da, Mr. Mo. Bist du Mr. Mo?
Nee?
Andere Dinge haben das, andere Menschen haben das getan.
Mr. Merz, ne Mx-Merz.
So, wenn es hier keine Schoki gibt, den jege ich jetzt.
Da, ich prange das auch an.
Das ist ein Tweet, der alle paar Monate, wow, das ist ja voll Meta. Fett. Direkt aus seinem Mitter eben. Aus der M-E-T-A eben. Also, sehr, sehr Fnordig auch wieder mal. Okay, das Niveau sinkt, die Stimmung steigt. Wir sollten langsam mit der Sendung ein Ende finden, auch um die Unterzuckerkranken endlich abliefern zu können.
Die Unterzuckerkranken.
So, jetzt kommt der Fnord euch holen. Will noch irgendjemand was sagen?
In welche letzten Worte?
Nee, nee, nee, mach Schluss, komm.
Mach aus.
Heute sind wir eh nur auf halber Zylinderkraft. Das wollten wir nicht machen, sondern...
Das war das Intro, nicht noch eine Sendung.
Genau, das reicht. Doch wir zeichnen jetzt schon gleich auf Vorrat auf, das wir gar nicht mehr können. So sieht's aus. Okay, für alle, die nicht genug kriegen können, in zwei Wochen gibt's die nächste Sendung. Bis dahin, sagen wir Tschüss, bis bald.
Er ist super geil, super geil, der du bist super geil. Es ist super geil, super geil, sie ist super geil, super geil. Er ist super geil, super geil, der du bist super geil.